e
e e
good morning um it's nine o'clock I
guess uh we'll get started there might
be a few people um still on their way in
and um our clerk is in training for a
while this morning um refresher course
for
her um but um my name is uh Glenn
cordelli um I'm the chair um
representative uh Christen Noble is vice
chair and uh representative Cornell is
the uh ranking minority
member um so we we welcome everybody
especially uh freshman um it's uh don't
feel intimidated it's always a learning
experience both um in the committee room
and on the house floor um and there's
always plenty of assistance um available
to you um so I thought first thing we
might do is uh go around and uh
everybody introduce themselves give a a
short bio um why you ran why you want to
be here um
uh anything you want to mention um but a
short bio um representative SEL would
you like to start us
off thank you Mr chair um I am Laurence
selig I represent the town of Durham um
and I am a former teacher of
kindergarten middle school high school
and graduate students getting certified
to become uh Middle School and High
School teachers and um I've also had a
few other careers bounc around in
between there thank you
thank you Mr chair I'm Megan Murray I
represent the towns of am Hurst and
Milford also intermediate Elementary
education was the area that I uh taught
in and I'm happy to be here so thank you
great thank
you good morning I'm lean kuger from
ward 3 in Nashua I have 30 years of
teaching experience I taught
kindergarten third grade fourth grade
fifth grade sixth grade and uh two
different gifted and talented programs I
ran
uh to be a representative because I
wanted to help the people of New
Hampshire become even better than what
we already have here and I'm passionate
about doing as much as we can for the
students in New Hampshire thank
you morning Mr chair Steve woodcart
calling New Hampshire uh this is my
fourth term on on this committee uh I
started off as a a teacher in the high
school level and moved to Administration
as a assistant principal and Dean and
the principal in Maine at principal in
Massachusetts it's been 12 Years A
department chair and teaching faculty
member of the college and I'm back here
again welcome
back thank you Mr chair um Muriel Hall
represent Bo and hopkington live in BO
I'm a 40-year educator I taught
computers um in recent years I also
taught math and special education and
I'm excited to be here I'm a child
advocate and that's my passion thank you
Patty Cornell I represent Ward Len in
Manchester um this is my sixth term here
the fifth on
education um I'm also a Manchester
Library trustee and a Waterworks
commissioner and it's been so long I
don't remember why I originally
ran I'm Kristen Noble I represent
Bedford um my my previous career I
worked in s Ware engineering uh before I
became a stay-at-home mom and I come at
education from the parent perspective we
had um two girls go through Public
School uh for a period of 17 years
they're very far apart in age um so I I
ran to
um uh improve things and and make uh I I
really want things to be the best that
they that they can be
and um and I hope that we can fix some
issues here the next couple
years thank you uh I'm Glenn cordelli
this is my seventh term all on the
education uh committee um my career was
in
it and um before I moved to New
Hampshire um I was on my uh Local School
Board in Connecticut um it would have
been the third largest um
uh District in New Hampshire where I was
um and so I've always been interested in
politics and uh decided to run um there
were things I wanted to accomplish uh
when I first ran and maybe a secondary
reason um my wife several terms ago sent
out a fundraising letter for me that
said um basically uh please donate to my
husband's campaign and help him get
reelected
because if he loses he's going to be
home all day and I don't know what I'm
going to do so um so that's why I'm
here thank you Mr chairman um my name is
Lisa Freeman I currently represent
Tilton samton in Belmont but I'm
formerly from Manchester and Boston if
anybody can tell um I am a retired 35y
year occupational therapist but more
importantly um I am the parent of a
child who's on the Spectrum I spent four
years on the Manchester school board so
and my primary reason for being here is
that um we can find ways to make it all
work and that's what I think we all
strive
for thank you Mr chairman uh Jeff tenza
representing Pelham this is my second
term uh I came over from the criminal
justice committee I'm a retired New
Hampshire state trooper after I retired
from the state police I taught in L
special ed for for six years uh right
now I'm a driver's ed instructor the
pelum High swim coach uh a dad so I
don't know what I don't do um it's a
pleasure to be on this on this committee
I think we're going to have a good time
and I ran because I'm absolutely crazy
uh but it's it's actually the people in
town I've lived in town uh for about 40
years and they just really wanted me to
to represent them as a voice thank you
and you did substitute on this committee
several times last year yes I did
yes thank you Mr chairman um hello
everybody my name is Brian Morris
Franklin uh District 2 um I'm a lineman
by trade currently but looking for
different occupation in the near future
um I originally ran because I saw our
country going in the wrong direction and
sometimes you got to just step up and
put your name out there and see if you
can make a
difference good morning everyone my name
is Valerie McDonald I represent Salem I
graduated from Salem High School in 2022
snhu last year I'm currently attending
Massachusetts school of law so my
experience
is less of an educator but more of the
student perspective perhaps more
contemporary perspective and my goal is
always to advocate for students the best
myability particularly as it relates to
special
education uh Valerie if I'm not mistaken
um um when you were elected uh last term
weren't you one of the youngest
representatives in the nation yes I was
last year
yes representative
litfield good morning my my name is
Melissa litfield I serve um Brentwood
Danville and
Fremont uh my experience is 15 years
school board and I served as a State Rep
2020 to 2022 during that time I also
served on the education committee oh and
I have four kids that's an education in
and of
itself morning everybody I'm Brian NATO
uh representing Raymond uh been paying a
lot of attention
to I guess some educational part of it
but a lot of political and my wife says
maybe it's time you should run you're
retired now I'm like let me pray on that
one uh but I do want to make sure the
kids are getting the proper education
and not going in a diff in a bad uh
Direction I I want us to excel I want
America to Excel and I would love to see
New Hampshire really Cel and and be a
Powerhouse in the education department
uh and I I want to get a lot of
information from all of you obviously
and uh I look forward to working with
you
all morning uh Paul Terry representing
uh Alton and Barnstead uh this is my
third term this will be my first
full-term on an education committee
having come over from Commerce uh where
I served for uh
two three three plus years uh I am an
ordained Presbyterian Minister 47 years
I'm honorably retired from active
service to a congregation which is why I
can be here as much as I am which is a
lot more than I thought I was going to
be when I was first
elected um I am a um economics and
political science uh major at the
undergraduate level
so I really enjoyed my my time on
Commerce because of the economics
background um I've done a fair amount of
educating in my uh in my career and
enjoyed it Lov
teaching and um I am looking forward to
making a contribution here uh during
this term which will enable us we've
heard an awful lot about how New
Hampshire is number one in this that and
the other thing and I would love to see
uh New Hampshire become number one in
the nation when it comes to
education great thank you uh thank you
all and um I think we're off to a great
start because oh I'm sorry didn't see
you sneak in
them hi I'm represent Peggy Balon I
serve Rockingham 38 which are at the
towns of Ry Northampton and Greenland
and I apologize to committee for my
lightness this morning um I uh must this
is my second term term I served on the
house education committee um the last
term and um I my background is I have a
master's in special education I've
served on my uh Town school board for
nine years uh uh curriculum committees
professional development committees and
the r public schools and uh also the
budget committee and I'm happy to be
here again thank you thank you um and I
I think we're off to a great start even
with the freshman um Everybody pressed
the button um to speak into the
microphone which is um
uh uh Quite a feat for a first time um
but uh I'm looking forward uh to this
year I think we've got um a a good
committee um and there's a lot we can
accomplish we'll have a lot of bills um
as uh most everybody knows um the
committee was split into two
um this year um in the past several
terms we have had um a huge number of
bills to try and get through over a
hundred house bills each year um so we
thought it was best to divide uh the
committee um we'll work work through um
the
uh Direction bills are sent um by
leadership um you know uh should it go
to funding or should it go to policy
Administration um so we'll work through
that this year we've we've already had
three bills that we've vacated and sent
to um uh the other committee um we'll
see if maybe there's a few more we can
get rid of along the way um but I expect
we'll have the majority of the bills um
we have 36 so far um only three early
bills um but we'll make a good progress
getting through them and um more to come
I I know um I I think that you know one
of the things I wanted to start off with
was um uh the committee um and that we
need to uh be civil and have respect for
each other uh and professionalism you
know I think that uh you know as an
education committee you know that's
definitely where we should be to setting
example um and that goes for you know
members um uh addressing members um and
also uh the public um when they come
they're our guests and uh they should be
treated as such um we should refer to
each other as
representative um and whoever is sitting
here um there'll be times when I have to
leave um to attend other hearings um as
soon as next week and so whoever is
sitting here is is always the
chair
um some housekeeping things um we have
our own office um as a uh standing
committee um office 205 right there will
be our office there are drawers for
everyone that um uh committee Services
has done a great job and and setting up
for us and if you're a returning member
your drawer here is already moved over
to there for you um and um the uh our uh
committee assistant is uh Karen Davis uh
she is located up um the last office on
this side of the
hallway and our committee researcher is
also the assistant director of um
committee services and that's Gen 4
right in the back um we know how uh um
what a resource she has been to uh to us
the past few terms and um is always
available for uh
questions um about the office also um
talking with representative Cornell
already this morning one of the
important things is that we've got the
the coffee machine set up um so that's
uh up and running thanks to uh
representative Cornell in our office and
um uh we'll look for someone maybe to um
keep track of the coffee machine to uh
in terms of
supplies um so you know be looking for a
volunteer for that assignment and you
know we'll set up a little um a cup you
know so maybe you throw it a doar in or
something when you get a cup of coffee
uh
or te or whatever um so uh that's um an
important uh important thing for many of
us um and in terms of that um uh they uh
say no food or drink um in the committee
room um you know water is fine coffee is
fine um I know I would certainly vote
for that and um food uh probably not
during hearings and exact session but
you know a few of us might you know have
lunch here um in the room uh especially
when we're uh um pressed for
time
um some of the other things um the way
we want to do things in the um in the
committee um is that uh um as I said
um representative is the uh name that we
should use for everybody um our goal is
to start our hearings on time and our
exec sessions on time um we'll try and
get information out um to everybody um
as soon as we can about um schedules for
the upcoming um week or two um uh
representive Cornell has the schedule
for next week and um we'll be passing it
around to uh our side of the aisle as
well um since Monday is a holiday next
week um we will meet on Wednesday and
Thursday uh our typical meeting days
will be Monday and
Wednesday um the other education
committee will meet Tuesday and Friday
and Thursday will be an open day um when
there isn't session for uh who wants to
be the first to schedule the
room um so um
so it will be Wednesday and Thursday
next week um in terms of cell phones and
laptops um I know that some PE I'm sorry
go ahead represent Sally thank you so
much um do you know what time we'll be
starting on those days just so I can
block it yeah um it might vary I think
next Wednesday we'll start at 9:30 and
on Thursday at 10: but hopefully more
like 9:30 as a standard
um I know some people have ways to
travel
um so
um laptops and cell phones I know some
people like to take notes maybe on uh
their laptop um rather than uh
handwright notes so that's fine um I
would just uh discourage um doing
searching and so forth uh uh especially
during hearings you want to pay
attention uh to the test testimony um
like with likewise with cell phones to
minimize um use of cell phones um you
know I think is um proper
practice
um see what else um public
hearings um we'll try and start them on
time um it's always a challenge uh to uh
anticipate the time the hearing is going
to take
um but um we won't start hearings early
um they'll hopefully be on time um but I
I'm sure there'll be times when a
hearing will run late and we'll have to
uh have a late start to a
hearing um and uh one thing in terms of
the hearings uh we want to respect the
people who are
testifying um the purpose of the hearing
is to get testimony from people uh to
listen and ask uh questions so we know
um what their Viewpoint is um but uh not
debate with people are who are
testifying um I'm sure we'll be doing
enough debating in our exact sessions um
to cover
that
um excuse me Mr chairman Mr Excuse me
along those same lines for those of us
who have U LED such boring lives at
times that we've actually watched C-SPAN
and uh committee meetings one major
difference between the New Hampshire
house and uh Congress is that um when we
question someone who is giving testimony
uh we can only ask one question we do
not have five minutes uh each to uh
engage in a back and forth with uh W
with a witness and if we wish to uh
follow up with a question we need to ask
the chair if we may follow up so that
for the benefit of the newcomers one
question and then you have to ask uh for
permission to follow if you'd like so we
cannot engage in colloques here or
anything of the sort just one at a time
thank you right yes and um yeah
everything comes through the chair um
request to uh ask questions um of people
testifying it all comes through the
chair and then a follow-up question if
you want as representa Terry pointed out
thank you um for those uh freshman
members
um the way it works is that there are
pink cards uh for people who want to
testify they sign up with um uh their
name and um whether they oppose or
support and an uh approximate time that
they want to speak um there might be
sometimes um if we have a very busy
schedule and a lot of people uh to
testify um there might be um uh times
uh set set up um by the chair uh for
people testifying um but uh hopefully um
that will uh not be uh too common U we
want to hear uh all that people have to
say and encourage people to uh provide
West testimony um for our clerk um
representative Margaret dra is our Clerk
and she is in uh clerk training uh this
morning uh for a little while
um uh one one thing also to point out um
there might be a time or two um when the
governor might come in uh to the room um
we have had uh Governor uh come in to
testify in the past on a couple of
occasions um if the governor ever uh
does come in um we would all stand um in
respect for the governor when when they
come
in let's see
subcommittees um there might be U bills
uh that we want to delve into a little
deeper um we didn't always have the time
to do that uh the past couple of terms
because of the crush of the number of
bills um so um there might be
subcommittees um appointed um to uh look
for fur into uh
legislation um and uh there would be a
number of people from uh both sides uh
appointed to the subcommittee and then
subcommittee will report back to
us um in executive sessions um uh that's
where there uh can be some debate and we
we know that we'll have some uh Hot
Topics um coming before the committee um
this year and every year so we just want
to try and um as I said be respectful of
everybody and not let emotions uh rule
the
day
um this being the first year of the term
um there are several motions we can make
in EXA session for newcomers there's the
standard ought to pass
OTP in expedient to legislate I
itl um or we can retain
bills um if we want to do more work on
the bill um we can retain the bill in
the committee um and have subcommittee
or a committee of the whole to address
that bill and work on it um over the
course of the um spring and uh fall um
will take uh um or the house takes off
usually July or August um when we don't
want to meet but um so retaining a bill
is a possible uh motion as well and then
we would report back um in um in the
fall as to whether we want to uh see
that uh legislation go forward um and
there can be worked on on amendments uh
during that period
also
um the outcome of our exec sessions are
um re
reports um or blurbs as we used to call
them that's not in favor these days but
I I still fall back to that um and these
reports would be U from the majority and
uh minority uh positions um if so
desired
um the um the mo the reports um can be
made and often are made by the person
who makes the motion um but that's
dependent upon um the leader of each um
minority or majority as to who does the
report um but uh I'm sure there will be
times um when we'll want to
caucus um and uh it's fine to uh for
anyone to ask for a caucus during an
exec session um if there's something
that comes up that they want to discuss
with uh with their caucus so um don't
hesitate to do
that um the reports um should be um the
position and not an
opinion um it's not I I believe or I
feel um more in the order of the
majority or the minority believes that
such and such
um reports would get turned in
um sometimes there might be a quick
turnaround in terms of when we need a
report from you um uh but the uh report
would go to your um your chairman or
your ranking member um we'll have a list
of the reports that are due and so we
can keep track and make sure that we we
get them all in a timely fashion um I
uh hesitate to ask for reports uh the
same day that we um
execel um so I I doubt that I'll be uh
doing that um at any point um but if
there are any questions about the
reports or uh report uh writing um see
your ranking member or you know uh chair
or vice chair um about
that uh because uh they are really
um what influences people on house
floor um and go into the permanent
record as um uh if anyone's looking in
the future about uh legislation and
intent and so forth um the reports are
uh key uh in that that
area
um see
[Applause]
um also um one option U me uh mentioned
uh for the new members um is the consent
calendar um there will be times um when
um we all all 18 of us agree um so um we
will ask um if consent is uh uh is okay
to be put on the consent calendar and
then there's just one vote in the house
on all the bills on the consent calendar
but we did have uh quite a number of um
times last year when we had uh a
considerable number of bills on the uh
consent calendar um so it's it's nice
when we can uh all come to a to
agreement on a piece of
legislation
um let's see is there anything else any
anyone have any questions or things that
they wanted to uh bring up um represent
yeah Representative no
Noble I just
um sometimes we can have hearings that
go like pretty long so don't feel shy
about getting up to take a break
um we just I would wait until the
Witnesses are going to switch and then
and then walk out as as there's a switch
and then act come back to your seat as
there's a
switch and hearings are not mandatory
attendance there'll be um times when you
have to go attend to another uh hearing
or want to see another hearing um or
can't make it in on a day um when um we
have hearings um so that's fine we can
always watch a video of of the uh of the
day um if we so desire um but for exact
sessions um it's different um because we
want um a Full Slate of the committee to
be here to to testify if it all to vote
on a legislation if it all possible um
the standard that was put into place and
continues is that if you cannot make it
in for an executive session
day uh to contact uh ranking member or
um Vice chair or chair the day before so
that we can arrange for a substitute uh
to sit in your
place um that's uh very important and um
there are going to be those times that
come up and um uh we um the office each
office will work to get substitutes for
us represent s thank you so much um on
the criminal justice committee our
chairman last year or the last term said
that if we were specifically testifying
on a bill that we were then not to be
asking questions of people other people
testifying on that same bill and I just
wasn't sure if you had the same policy
or or if it depended on context yes
thank you for bringing that up yes um
yeah we'd prefer that you not um ask
questions if you've testified um on
legislation um
um even uh you can remain in the back
after you
testify
um but uh yeah it's uh probably the best
to let um other people um ask their
questions if you've testified uh because
you do have a a Viewpoint that you've
put into the
record resident woodcot thank Mr CH I
have two questions I may if I ask for
the followup now um
the first one uh chair in terms of
executive session your intent to
schedule the date so the public will
know when they're going to be versus
having them at the end of the the um
dialogue um and I'll wait for that
response before I follow up yeah um we
will put um into the calendar the um uh
the language that uh has been agreed
upon um in terms of an executive session
U may follow um if time permits um but I
anticipate uh um letting everybody know
um when uh what what bills will be EXA
so for instance uh next Wednesday um we
will be uh executing the bills that um
we will hear this
afternoon um so those will be in the
calendar so I'll try and do that as much
as uh possible um but there also might
be some days when we uh uh bypass a bill
that was even in the calendar for exec
and pull that over for the next week um
if we want to look at that some more but
um yeah we'll try and let everybody know
when we are executing bills and there'll
be times uh possibly too where we have a
hearing and um based on the questioning
you know I'll ask the ranking member um
how uh their caucus feels about
legislation and um we could even move
directly into um exec session and vote
on a bill that um uh we're pretty much
uh uh unanimous on which I think is uh
something we did last term as well one
more follow up thank you a different
topic however um the first uh time I was
here eight years ago the
protocol um when I went to caucus was
that you may recall that both parties
left so it allow the respect of the
guests uh here
uh and for those who haven't been here
typically all those seats are full we
have a hearing and everybody stands out
in the hallway so um since both areas
are open um is it possible this year as
a courtesy to the people coming to
witness the program and speak that when
you we call a clus said both parties
leave the room so the guests may stay
here instead of standing the allall um I
I'll see depending on the numbers um but
um yeah I had uh thought that for the
most part we would do it the same way we
did last year and that uh the majority
will stay here okay um the office is a
perfect place um for us now that we have
our own office so that that would be a
no the majority is going to stay in the
room most mostly no okay thank
you uh yes representative Freeman thank
you um Mr chair um piggybacking on the
representative's question about um
testifying
and um at that point you shouldn't ask
any questions would that metric stand
for people who sponsor or co-sponsor
bills that have brought in front of
house education who sit on this
committee um yeah that's um a good
question I I would think that if you're
a prime sponsor um you would not uh ask
uh questions um of um those
testifying um
uh co-sponsor if you're not
testifying um if I think if you ask a
respectful question
um really looking for
information um I I don't have a problem
with
that thank you sure uh represent
Terry uh Mr chairman I noticed that
there are at least two members on the
committee who are uh brand new first
term uh serving uh not only on the
committee but also here in the house and
so under the category of I I remember uh
what it was like when I first began to
serve on a committee and I saw uh a
schedule for bills that are going to be
heard and I looked at uh at the schedule
and I thought all right the first one
will be at 1:30 the second will be at
2:15 and the third will be at 300 p.m.
as in
today and uh that that's not exactly how
it went a lot of times and so for your
benefit
particularly um here's the bad news if
if the bill that we hear today at 1:30
the hearing is over in 10 minutes
nevertheless we have to wait until 2:15
and I think that makes sense because
people may be coming uh specifically to
uh to hear or to testify on the bill at
215 but here's the here's the real bad
news and that is that if the bill that
is being heard at 1:30 for example goes
on for 45 minutes to an hour or an hour
and a half that's what happens we don't
stop at 2:15 and then go on to the next
bill we hear everybody who comes
questions are asked and so forth so if
you're if you're thinking that um the
schedule is the schedule it's kind of
sort of like the schedule with the uh
commentary that I just provided we we do
have the option of of recessing a here
hearing um and then coming back later in
the day um or um at a future date um
certain so that is an option yes thank
you Mr chair just to followup luckily I
plan when I come here I'm going to be
here till 10 p.m. 8 900 p.m. whenever so
I I I I I would say that you don't have
to plan on those hours
uh representative
lville thank you for taking my question
I two questions if that's okay um one is
superficial but important to me um let's
just say hypothetically speaking and if
it's no I understand hypothetically
speaking someone has maybe never ever
drank a drop of coffee in their entire
life and not a huge fan of water or
green vegetables um is diet soda allowed
sure here yeah okay thank you um and
then my second question is um regarding
the bills I'm just wondering if it's
possible for us either to get the print
outs of the bills a week ahead of time
for us to prepare or even possibly I
don't know whether this makes sense or
not but let's say we have 36 at this
point if we even had them printed in the
three-hole paper punch I know for me I
use like you do the notebook to keep
them in and if there are some of us that
maybe they might get misplaced you can
keep it in your drawer in the office
just throwing it out there but I'm
wondering if we can get it even a week
ahead of time to prepare or possibly all
ahead of time yeah um thank you good
good questions I wanted to bring up
copying also um you have some I think
information from um house committee
Services uh on your desk um contact
information and so forth um up on the
fourth floor uh they are happy to make
uh copies for you um if you have an
amendment or information you want to
provide uh to the committee um uh you
can uh take it or email it up to them um
there's their email address on there
it's just
ACS well whatever the new address is
going to be um and um yeah uh some of us
do like notebooks so um I think a a rule
of thumb would be uh um three hole
request three hole punched um and uh
also
double-sided um as a um a
possibility uh if
possible um but uh yeah they're great in
terms of U making copies and if you get
off the elevator on the left there are
folders um and um they will put your
copies in there um with a little uh
sticky note with your name on
it
um and we are also um having uh the
printer uh in our office set up uh so we
can mail things to the
printer um for printing um specifically
um attachments to an email you can email
it to whatever the printer name is um
and the attachment would be printed um
so that's um an option if um required um
in a short space of time um but uh HCS
and Jen who is often here um are uh very
helpful in terms of getting copies made
for us when
needed y um back to the the the bills
they will be printed for us uh it's
being worked on right the um yeah many I
was so afraid you were going back to the
diet Pepsi not the bill
um no we have a a number of bills
um uh left on the desk for us
um when we see the bill online as
available um there is still a lag time
uh for
printing um so we don't get them um as
uh quickly as uh you might see them
online but um uh Karen Davis our clerk
um is working
uh to uh get them printed and available
to us um as soon as um they get copies
of our bills so that we definitely
should have uh the bill uh available for
the
hearing that should not be a problem
yes uh question Mr chair um as far as
when you file a
bill uh when is a deadline for final uh
uh approval of the written
bill before you get to vote uh to go to
committee yeah like an amendment or the
B uh well amendments I I guess right up
until the last moment correct but a
final uh print out of a bill so we can
examine
it um well if if you're the prime
sponsor you've already signed off on it
okay right um or a co-sponsor if you
want a co-sponsor bill you have already
signed off on it um before it actually
becomes a
bill
um so
uh yeah with
amendments um you would send submit the
uh proposed amendment to legislative
Services just like submitting a bill um
and uh I think they have a form now
about um uh with information that they
want when you submit uh an amendment um
but you definitely have to give them a a
time frame on when you need that
Amendment back um and then they will
email you the um the bill um and that's
when you could send it up to HCS to have
the copies
made yes so I just want to be uh clear
uh and by way of example there was an
email that um that I saw I think I saw
in any event we have bills that are
going to be considered next
week
um so if we want access to paper copies
of those bills prior to next week before
we actually walk into the Committee
hearing that day uh did I hear you say
that those would be available to us
prior to next Wednesday next week that's
something that's being worked on now I
think we have hard or do we just go and
search for these on gen the three that
we have today I think we have copies of
yes right and um uh we should have hard
copies when we come in I don't know
about hard copies prior um especially
when they're trying to get all the bills
printed um you know later on in the
session it it it won't be a problem but
right now when they have a a backlog of
um bills to even get to printing um U
printing has a backlog as well okay so
so just to be clear then for for
everybody that means that when we
receive notice of the meeting next week
and a list of the bills that are going
to be heard next week that if if any
member would want to examine those bills
prior to the date of the committee
meeting the hearing on those bills you
would go to gen Court website and you do
a search for those bills save them on
your computer or print them out or
whatever but otherwise you would not see
them until you actually walk in the room
for the committee meeting as the way
things have stand right now and have
been in the past right and um yeah I I
definitely um encourage everyone to look
at the bills um in advance because uh
you'll uh always uh come up with
questions you'll be wanting to ask at
the
hearings yes I just received a text from
somebody who's trying to watch this on
YouTube and the TV is
blocking um oh some of
the um we'll see if we can um get that
moved a little bit um yeah I'll check
check on that uh yes
um uh Diana Fenton from the Department
um we will be hearing from uh about uh
education law and our books um and uh
has some things to present um on the
screen so um we'll see if we can get
them to to move the screen a little bit
for us okay um if there no other
questions um you know we have a a 10
minutes until 10 o' and um we'll see if
we can get screen moved in the meantime
okay thank you everybody
e
e e
okay I I think we're ready to uh
proceed
um uh that's pretty much
is uh the best we can do with the
screen um but uh I'd like to welcome uh
Diana Fenton um lawyer with the
Department of Education
um and a great resource for us and helps
us out uh throughout the year um
especially when um we would like to have
U uh someone from the Department attend
a
hearing um but uh Diana is going to uh
lead us through a little bit about um
education law and our law books our new
law books um I think it's the first time
I've ever seen them on our first day of
uh committee work um so thanks to
everyone involved uh but um Diana the
floor is
yours well good morning everyone um you
all set the bar really high and I knew I
had to remember to turn on my microphone
as I sat down so kudos to you because I
always forget to turn on my microphone
and I also assume that because I'm an
attorney I'm just naturally loud um but
uh thank you all for having me here and
thank you all for your service um I am
an attorney with the Department of
Education I'll be the first to tell you
I am uh not from the field of Education
um however I am a product of New
Hampshire public education I graduated
from kennet high school um in Conway the
year shall remain confidential um and uh
we just had a little uh group meeting
over here that apparently we we all have
a connection to the same undergrad
College that I went to that no one has
ever heard of until this very moment
where I've met more people that have
that connection that I've ever met so um
my mom was a special ed teacher in New
Hampshire and when I called her and told
her I was going to law school her uh
reaction was I don't like those people
and I really want you to be a teacher so
this job is really just to make my mom
happy um and to to thank all the
Educators out there and all their hard
work uh so I want to talk to you today
about the role of the department we
present in a very different way than a
lot of the testimony you're going to
hear because we are here to provide
technical assistance we do not support
or oppose any bill but we can find
information for you um we'll go over our
website a little bit but we really are
just to provide that technical support
technical assistance to say this is how
the department would interpret this this
is what the department needs this is
what the department can offer and that's
very different testimony from a lobbyist
or a parent or a citizen that you will
obviously hear from um and so
again sometimes people will ask us what
do you think of this and the answer is
we have no opinion that is for you to
decide um but I wanted to go over the
law books with you and just give you
some ideas of how to best use the law
books they can be a little daunting at
times but I want to make it very um kind
of user friendly and accessible for you
as we go through please feel free to ask
questions um because again I'm an
attorney I like to talk so if you have a
question please feel free to redirect me
so there's a couple of ways first of all
everyone loves having the paper copy of
the law book but you can find the laws
online multiple
ways and I will just toggle out of this
very
quickly if you go to our website we have
the laws on our website and we have the
lawbook reprinted on our website and
that's great if you like to just do the
control F excuse me are you going to
would you be able to make these slides
available to the members of the
committee when you're finished because I
I can't even see what's up there from my
angle yes so I just have to rely on my
ear thank you sure we can do that for
you of course
oh there you go is that better and
you're going to be very good friends
with uh representative next to you
um there you go so we do have the law
book on our website that you can find
that and that's a great resource if You'
like to do the control F function we are
also going to talk about the index of
this book and how best to use
it we also have
uh the rules some technical advisories
on our website but we will get into
those as we go through this
presentation so it's very fitting at
this moment that everything has seemed
to have Frozen up on me here so give me
just a
minute oh there we go all right and
we're back so we're going to start with
RSA 21n so if you want to follow along
in your law book you certainly can
what's interesting about the education
laws is they cover an enormous amount of
material that may or may not be relevant
to this
particular legislative session and there
will be times where you suddenly find
yourself in a
chapter that you have not ever referred
to and this is not the kind of book that
you would take home and read and I
always suggest to people that's just not
going to be an effective measure the way
to do it is to take the law I know there
was a lot of discussion about getting
the bills ahead of time I think that's a
great suggestion because the key to
success is to take that proposed Bill
and put it into context with the
chapter open it up and put it into
context and see what the bill is
proposing is it adding a new section is
it repealing something is it amending a
current section and put it into context
text with the bill and the law as
currently written so we're going to
start very briefly with
21n and 21n just talks about the the
setup of the department now when um the
commissioner edelblute first started he
did um a consolidation of the department
and so we had bills pertaining to 21n of
how the department was divided all the
different division directors who Mo most
of you met on Monday at the law Day
presentation at the department those are
all created
statutorily so 21n establishes the
department and the duties of the State
Board 21 N9 talks about the board's
rulle making Authority and I want to be
really careful in our language there
because oftentimes we will say the
Department's rule making Authority but
the department does not have ruem
authority it is the state board that has
rulem Authority and that is a critical
distinction between the Department of
Education and most other state
agencies and it might sound kind of
picky and nuanced and I'm a lawyer I get
paid really well to be picky and nuanced
but it is a critical distinction that
the rul making Authority belongs to the
state board and we're going to talk
about what rul making Authority looks
like in the proposed bills that you will
be considering
and again what we're doing today is
really just a highlevel 10,000 foot
overview of the laws that we anticipate
will come before you and just to give
you that
familiarity so as I go along if you have
an area that you want to discuss at more
depth I'd be happy to do that because
this really is going to be a cursory
overview I want to point your attention
out to RSA 186
11 when I first started at the
Department of Education I had a
wonderful co-counsel who used to just
tell me the page number of the book
because I was leaping through it and it
took me so long that she would just lose
patience with me and go it's on page 335
and I thought that was so helpful I do
that to commissioner edelblute and he
says I can find the law don't give me
the page number but for those of us who
like the page number it's on page 335 I
find it very
helpful if you look at RSA
18611 this is a really interesting law
because it kind of mirrors 21 N9 the rul
making
Authority it talks about the duties of
the State Board of educ
a I highlight this for a couple of
reasons you will find sections in this
book that are very close to being
duplicative of other sections but you
have to read both of them because there
will be areas that are covered in one
that are not covered in the other there
is a reason the legislature passed it so
when we look at
1861 duties of the State Board of
Education I'm going to bring your
attention
attention to Roman
numeral 9 C and 9 D and it's at this
moment in time that I take a pause and
think I hope I just said that Roman
numeral correctly because every time I
look at the Super Bowl I'm like I have
no idea what number that is so I think
it is 9 C and 9d if I'm wrong please
feel free to correct me but every year
these two sections are come for this
this policy committee these are hot
button topics uh the first one is
requiring the school district to adopt a
policy allowing an exception to course
material and uh 9d is adopting a policy
governing the uh administration of
nonacademic surveys and questionnaires I
cannot think of a legislative session
that has
not at least considered a bill that
covers that law
represented cordelli have
you
it's there you there you go what I like
about
18611 9d and I want to point it out for
you so now I'm looking at page
336 and I'm in the leftand
column and I'm under the heading
9d and as you look at that
paragraph I want to highlight for you
that it is at the very bottom of the
paragraph where it gives the definition
of the term non-academic survey or
questionnaire that definition becomes
critical to your analysis as a
legislator your work as a policy
maker and it's interesting because as we
go through this book in most of the
chapters and most of the titles
you will see the definition section set
out and set
apart and it's very clear what the
definitions are but it is not
necessarily clear in
9d if you're anything like me you take
your highlighter and you highlight that
definition section because I can tell
you as an attorney having read this
section many times having written about
this section it always surprises me that
the definition is at the very bottom oh
please come on in take your
time in this same section of
law right around in the middle of the
paragraph and I have mine
underlined they talk about the youth
risk behavior survey as developed by the
Centers for Disease Control and
prevention
you will hear that term youth risk
behavior
survey short-handed as the
yrbs and when people from the Department
come to testify they will refer to it
very quickly and succinctly as the
yrbs and I will share with you on a
personal note I think I F I spent the
first year of my time at the Department
of Education going the what I had no
idea what the yrbs was and people said
it so quickly and so confidently I
thought well I should probably just nod
and smile and play along but I don't
want you to have that same experience so
it is the youth risk behavior survey and
you will hear it be called the yrbs this
is a very controversial hot button topic
is that a fair assessment I don't want
to speak out of turn again our role is
really to just provide that technical
assistance but I have yet to experience
a legislative session where this law has
not been discussed so
18611 Roman numeral D and as you see
there are other sections in this law
that also could come before you for your
consideration so we're going to move
ahead to
18660 and this governs the Professional
Standards Board I know that last session
this provision came before this
legislative body I'm not sure if there's
another um one this session but there
might be next year and I'm on page
344 and you'll see it set out on the
leand side there 186 col 60 Professional
Standards Board very quickly we call it
the PSB and it is a body that advises
the state board about areas of
professional practice for
educators and so it's used in our
certification Bureau um to make those
decisions as to what a certification for
a social studies teacher might look like
or a math teacher and from time to time
the legislature will have the
opportunity to look
at the makeup of the
PSB and I think last session there was
an addition of Career Technical
education and so that's an area that's
always kind of growing and changing as
the field grows and changes and the PSB
keeps Pace with that and advises the
certification Bureau of
that any questions as we're going along
like I said this a very kind of cursory
10,000 foot
overview special education I know this
was talked about on Monday um special
education is governed by
186c and it is a lengthy area of the
law and we
start on page 351 you'll see the heading
of the chapter at the very
bottom on the right hand
side what I want to highlight for you is
that table of content
for the start of the chapter so it
starts a little bit on page 351 but if
you look at
352 that table of contents can be very
helpful to you to you as a legislator it
breaks
down all the various headings this is a
really good tool for you to use as you
dive into special education
law because it sets it all right out
here and you'll see these little
subheadings such as alternative dispute
resolution it's bolded you'll find it
near the bottom of the column on the
leftand side that's kind of like a
little subsection within special
education you'll also find one for the
advocate for special ed education again
another little subheading but it tells
you how the chapter is
created and it's a great tool to to use
couple of things to be aware of in
2022 legislation was passed to amend the
definition making special education
applicable to ages 3 and 21
inclusive from time to time there will
be what we call cleanup bills or
technical bills where we have found
other areas of the law that did not get
this new definition
and so the department will often times
flag those areas bring a request forward
to say we need to make sure the
definition is consistent in other
chapters in other areas of the law
that's very common but we call those
technical bills or cleanup
Bill I know there was also the
discussion about catastrophic Aid I know
yesterday in the um Committee hearing
for representative lad he said I always
call it CAD a and now I'm being told not
to call it CAD Aid that is true there's
a legislative fix to address that it is
no longer catastrophic Aid special
education Aid
right we're going to keep moving along
in this book and in some ways we're
doing this Justice and in other ways
you're getting to know the complexity of
some of these chapters I would suggest
to you as a practical matter
these little poits and those tabs that I
always used to ignore when i' go into
Staples could be very helpful to you
when I started in law
school these are great because they're
going to really help you to just flip to
the right page and identify what
chapters you're working on as you go
into your
policym career in technical education
CTE again I cannot imagine a legislative
session where there is not a proposed
bill on CTE so
188e is the chapter that governs Career
and Technical
education I'll just note that uh most of
the CTE bills will be going to the uh
other committee that is one of their
areas of responsibility
but it's still good to be able to refer
to it back here for us
we talked a little bit about rule
making rule making can only be done if
it is granted
legislatively so when the legislature
wants the department to create rules and
the way I describe the difference
between a statute and the
rules is that the statute is kind of the
framework of the house if you will right
it's the framework of the house and the
rules flush it out the rules are the
wallpaper and the paint and the
carpeting right and so there's a big
difference when you're driving to your
house and you see someone's building a
house and you watch it over time come
together you see the framework and then
you see the final product and that's how
I think about the difference between the
law and the rule and if the legislature
wants the department and the State Board
to engage in rule
making 18 a e3 is a really good example
of the language to use so first of all
you have to the legislature has to say
and it's right in paragraph one the
State Board shall adopt rules pursuant
to RSA
541a and RSA 21n 911 a direct citation
to the rule making Authority those are
the magic words for Ru
making but as representative cordelli
and I have discussed in the
half it
is a good practice for the legislature
to tell the state board and the
department what the rules should
cover and this particular statute does a
really good job with that because it say
it states the rules shall include
criteria which guarantee potential
sending districts an opportunity to
enroll students it gets into the
detail of what the legislature is
directing the state board and the
department to do rulle making
on and that is going to make for a very
effective rule making there have been
other instances where the rul making
Authority is listed pursuant to 541a Ru
making as it pertains to this chapter
that's very general that's very generic
and it might not it might not produce
what the legislative body is hoping it
will produce the more detail that can be
given think the better the product will
be and so I highlight that for this
committee because I think this is a
really great
example of using that rule making
Authority so as you consider these bills
keep that in the back of your mind is
Rule making
Necessary are the directions clear as to
what this ruem should cover or is Rule
making Necessary do we want to give the
department more direction as to what
this should look
like the other area in this particular
chapter that I want to highlight for you
is on page
432 that page number reference thing
seems to be working quite well I think I
like that I might have started a trend
here um so at the bottom on the left
hand side 188 E8 I'm going to highlight
this for you you you'll see some
language in italics and
brackets anytime something is in italics
and brackets in the world of law it's
really important right there was a joke
in law school once that in your normal
life you don't read footnotes but in law
school you do it's kind of the same
thing here take a look at that language
and it's telling you that this
particular provision is is effective
until a certain date and
time and after that you have a whole new
section and you find it on the next
column so depending on when you're
reading this one of them is effective
and the other one is not and that can
become very
critical also critical when you see that
as to when the effective date is so when
you're considering bills think about
when that effective date be kicks
in we're now going to turn to
189 and
189 is a pretty
significant chapter on school
administrations and I'm just going to
highlight a couple of key
areas 189 colon 11
which is on the bottom of page
485 but really you'll find it on page
486 uh again I cannot think of a
legislative session that did not
consider uh 18911 instruction in
National and State history government
and
Civics I would be surprised if there was
not another bill put forward that is an
area um that is always up for debate in
this legisl body often will look at that
address some areas that need some
technical fixes or add to that
section the department also does and
we'll take a look at this but we do a
lot of technical
advisory as the laws change and this is
an area that we will often uh draft and
release technical advisories
on I also want to bring your
attention to
18913a and you're going to find that on
page
491 there's three areas to be aware of
here there's 18913 a b and
c as we said 18913a is on page 491
1891 13B is on
and 8913 C is also on the very bottom of
that
page
18913a talks about employment and
background checks for teachers and
Volunteers in school districts charter
schools at public
cies
non-public that deals with
employment so when an educator is hired
by a school
district they are subject to a criminal
background check and according to this
chapter the school district reviews that
criminal history
record there are a list of criminal
offenses that would prohibit someone
from working as an educator anywhere in
the
state those offenses are
found on the bottom of page
492 in section five Roman numeral five
of this
provision because of the placement in
Roman numeral 5 the shorthand is we call
them the section five violations it's
not because there's five violations it's
because they're in Roman numeral 5 when
you look at Roman numeral 5 those
criminal offenses are all listed by
Statute number they're not written out
as to what those offenses
are I'll be very plain about it this is
not
helpful this just adds a layer of
complication I took a look at this
chapter and thought oh good lord I don't
even know what those are so I wrote them
down because I'm a big fan of knowing
what I'm talking about and having the
little cheat sheet so I know somewhere
Jen yeah you already have the gch
perfect those are the list of all the
offenses that would prohibit someone
from working in a
school
Statewide from time to time the
department has worked with this
committee to add to that
list I'm not aware of any um proposed
changes for this legislative SE
session but it is not unheard of that
the department will come forward with
that with that
request interestingly enough while those
disqualifying offenses and that's
exactly what they are they are
disqualifying
offenses a school
district can take into account any
offense that's on an individual's record
they have an enormous amount of
discretion to say what is the right fit
for our classroom what is the right fit
for this
job that is in sharp contrast
however to the Department's
Authority when the department does a
background check on a individual who
wants a license to teach and you're
going to find that in
C the department has authority to do a
background
check on an applicant to teach so so
that's either someone from a teacher
prep program or someone from out of
state who is now seeking to teach here
in New Hampshire the department will run
a background
check um and if that individual has one
of those section five violations on
their record they're not granted a
license if there's anything else on that
record the department does not have
discretion to say well maybe we should
still go ahead with it or maybe this
person's not qualified we do not have
that discretion we leave that discretion
to to the individual
districts but these two sections 189 13B
and 13 C were created by this
legislative body in the last 8 n 10
years and the reason for that was we
were recognizing that the department had
to play a role
in assessing whether someone should be
granted a license to teach um and the
decision was made that if someone wasn't
employable they didn't pass the section
five test if they were not employable
the department shouldn't license them
because turning them out to the field
was not helping the
field but that was a policy debate that
happened in this
committee I don't want to glance over
1891 13B so that allows the department
to do the background check for school
bus
drivers you probably uh are familiar
that we had and probably still have a
school bus
shortage and one of the reasons for that
was that they were background checked
for employment purposes that limited and
forgive the pun but that limited their
Mobility to go and work for another
district and so we housed it with the
Department of Education they get
licensed to drive a bus with the
Department of Motor
Vehicles and then the department of
education does that background
check the way that I remember it
18913a deals with
employment employment school districts
all that 18913 b b for bus
driver and 18913 C for
credentialing that's the easiest way to
recall that those sections all overlap
they all reference the same list of
disqualifying offenses those section
five
violations but the implications of them
can be very different from employment to
lure any questions on that yes dang in
it so if the if the department is going
to do credentialing and do the criminal
background check and find that they
shouldn't get their credential yeah they
shouldn't be even getting as far is
possibly being hired by a school
district because they won't have a
credential anyway correct that's that's
correct yes okay yeah and the the idea
and thank you for the
question the idea was that the
department was not doing a background
check
historically and so they would license
the individual not run the background
check and then that person would apply
to a school district and the school
district would then find out well
they're not employable and so as a
policy matter the department came before
this legislative body and said we would
like to change that moving forward
policy-wise the department did not want
to license individuals who were
unemployable we didn't see that as a
benefit to to the
districts however there was a lot of
policy debate as to what role the
department would play in that and the
decision ultimately was that the
department
was stuck with those not stuck with but
could only run for and check for the
section five disqualifying offenses and
has no discretion as it pertains to
other offenses and the discretion is
left to the the school
districts yes thank you attorney Fon can
you refresh me on the student teaching
uh certification when the the schools do
that credentialing applicants yes yes so
thank you for the question so that's
governed in 18913
C and you'll see the definition
credentialing applicant versus
candidate and I don't want to get too
far into the weeds
um but the history of it and I think
this is what you're
referencing is there was a time where if
we say St anam's College St a
they would have a teacher prep
program
and they would background check the
students and then those students as part
of that teacher prep program would go
into a multitude of schools around the
districts for observation or Hands-On
work anything in this area that deals
with criminal background
checks doesn't just fall within the
purview of the Department of Education
there is significant overlap with the
Department of
Safety and you'll recall that from prior
legislative years where I will testify
and then someone with a badge and a gun
and a really cool hat will come and
testify from the Department of Safety
there's overlap and the reason there's
overlap is the Department of Education
does not have we don't have access to
nor do we house an individual's criminal
record that in that information is
exclusively with the Department of
safety what happened with the teacher
prep
programs is the Department of Safety was
told by the
FBI you cannot release the federal the
the federal background check to a
non-governmental
entity that was the history that's what
kind of caused the snag here um because
St a is
private and while they could get an
individual state record the New
Hampshire record they could not get that
federal background check and without the
federal background
check that's a big piece of information
that might be missing some critical
information so when the department
looked at this and worked with our
partners at the department of
safety we realized that we are a
governmental entity
we can receive the federal background
check and so we worked with um the
chacher prep programs to say we will
take on that role we can background
check these individuals and then they
can participate in this program and go
into this various
schools now the individual schools can
also say we would like a background
check that's well within their right but
that's kind of the the history it's
probably you're probably recalling it as
we're going through it thank but that's
that's the issue there so anything that
deals with this area the department
cannot speak to this issue alone because
the department of safety has to have a
voice in that right anything with
background checks and we found that as
well um with doing a background check on
educational surrogates and educational
surrogates are part of special ed law
so we go back to
186c we're in a whole different chapter
and yet we still have to work with the
Department of Safety to say how do we
background check successfully background
check our educational
surrogates what's so interesting as you
look at this law book is the inherent
Crossover with all these different areas
of the law so you look at
them in an island a little bit but the
reality is there's just inherent
crossover I think that's fascinating but
I this is probably why no one hangs out
with me so there you
go I think it's cool um just as a little
side note uh legislatively some of the
things the department has successfully
worked with this body to do is the
department also now um before it issues
a license to an individual to
teach the department does a check of the
New Hampshire DCF division of children
youth and families their central
registry to make sure that individual
does not have a finding of
abuse not neglect but just abuse that
was a policy
determination that the the department in
this legislative body if some if an
individual had a finding of abuse by
DCF the decision was made that the
Department of Education
was not to license that individual and
provide them access to children but that
was a legislative decision and that is
found in the
laws
additionally there is
aou which is a memorandum of
understanding and that's a very common
term in state
governmentus memorandum of understanding
um the Department of Education has a
number of M with DHHS Department of
Health and Human Services because
there's an enormous amount of crossover
between the Department of Education and
DHHS but more to the point the
Department of Education wanted to expand
the ability to check the central
registry we wanted to be able to check
in
Massachusetts it is no secret that
there's a lot of crossover employment
wise New Hampshire sends a lot of
Educators to Massachusetts and vice
versa so we we worked with this
legislative body to create a law that
allows a
department within the parameters of a an
anou to check the Massachusetts central
registry they call their division um DCF
division CH Children and Families just a
little different vernacular than in New
Hampshire but those were all done
legislatively working with the
department and this legislative
body any questions on on this area
because it can get very complex very
quickly again very quickly this is the
10,000 F foot overview um just based on
my experience and working with
representative cordelli as to the areas
we believe um you will see with the
bills that are coming before you
is
1933 and
1933 is on page
537 and its change of school or
assignment
and it's called best interest of student
that's the title of it but when you read
through it it's best interest in
manifest educational
hardship and that term manifest
educational
hardship is a critical term to know it's
interesting that it's not in the title
of the bill but that's what this law
really talks
about and it is a rare occasion when
this legislative body does not consider
1933 1933 has been looked at worked on
and expanded over over the years quite a
bit it is worth taking a look at
1933 I will never be an advocate for
anyone taking this book home and reading
it cover to cover that's just not a good
use of your time uh the only person who
does that is me but I would
suggest prior to considering a bill that
amends 1933 that you read over
1933 it's worth looking at at what it
covers and what it says because it has
been changed quite a
bit but when you hear that term manifest
educational hardship and it's a common
term they're referring to 1933 even
though it's not in the title
while we're in this chapter it's also
worth just highlighting for your
reference
19313 which is the suspension and
expulsion of
pupils this is not an area that's
addressed all the time by this
legislative body but I do recall a few
sessions ago that there was an amendment
to
19313 it's a very complex area and I
just flag it for your attention on the
off chance that is brought before you in
a in a proposed bill
193f which is on page
600 this is commonly referred to as the
bullying law
every November the Department of
Education reports out to the state board
and then the legislative body um
instances of bullying and restraint and
seclusion and so there's a a board
meeting every November where the
department will present those numbers to
the state board and then we compile the
report and we present it to the general
court um that information is all on our
website but we look at those two areas
restraint and
seclusion and bullying and I know there
were some discussion and some questions
about what the department reports out
and if we can kind of refine what the
department is reporting on we did see I
believe instances of bullying in Middle
School go up I don't have the numbers in
front of me but I have I I think there
is a a proposed bill that will seek to
amend uh
193f so this chapter
193f pupil safety and violence
prevention probably worth flagging you
will be just looking at
that and again you know when you get
that proposed bill it's great to put it
into context with the entire chapter and
look at what that proposed bill is
seeking to do is it adding another
provision is it amending something is it
repealing a provision is it amending a
definition and if it amends a definition
how does that new
definition in context how is that going
to play out in the in the rest of the
chapter are there other cross references
to be aware
of when you look at the
definitions it's interesting that every
section will have a different definition
and when I first started with the
Department of Education I found it
interesting if not frustrating that
there are different definitions of
student
depending on what section of the law
you're looking
at there could be times where you want
to be this legislative body wants to be
consistent in the
terminology there have been areas where
we're very inconsistent with the
terminology teacher versus educator
that's a very common
one so think about as as you consider
these policy matters and consider these
propos bills that consistent with
consistency and
terminology I'm going to turn your
attention to 194b and then with
representative cordell's permission
we'll just take a quick five minute
break um but
194b is chartered Public
Schools I know there was a lot of
discussion on Monday about home
education and chartered Public
Schools you're going to find chapter
194b on page
633 I want to highlight for your
consideration and
attention 194
b1a which is the statement of purpose
and also 194
B3 and if I may I'll read to you
directly from 194
B3 and it says except as otherwise
provided in law chartered Public Schools
shall be fully exempt from state laws
and
rules which otherwise apply to public or
non-public schools or local school
boards or
districts it has similar language in the
purpose statement 194
b1a Roman numeral
5 exempt charter schools from State
statutes and rules other than where
specified so what does that
mean it means that as you are
considering other laws that
amend other
chapters if it is the intent of this
legislative body to have that law be
applicable to Charter Schools it has to
state that it has to explicitly state it
if it doesn't explicitly state it 194b
says charg of schools are exempt because
the assumption is the legislative body
wrote it the way they wanted it to
read and so when you look at things like
we're going to flip back here 1893
a it states charter schools and it
states charter schools because the
legislative body wanted the background
checks to apply equally to Charter
Schools that's why you have to list
those things out and when I say you
please I don't mean it in a dismissive
derogatory sense I'm trying to say
legislative body as much as I can but I
want to highlight the importance of that
so these are things to consider as you
think about these bills debate these
bills and ultimately write
them who is it applicable to because
when you look at
18913a and you look at how it's written
and this is again the background check
for
employment you read through paragraph
one and it lists out all these different
schools when I first read it I thought
there's got to be a way to consolidate
it it's not written very well to be
honest with you and I can say that
because I wrote a lot of it it's not
written very well it's very
verbose but there's a reason for that
because the legislature wanted to say
this is applicable to all these
different
entities and that's why I highlight that
for you on
194b I have not found another provision
that
exempts in that fashion
so again this is very much a kind of
10,000 foot overview other areas um that
representative cordelli and I wanted you
to just be aware
of is
18966 Miss Fenton if I could just
mention I believe that there you
mentioned um the charter school chapter
194b and I think that there are people
within the department who are looking to
try and and
reord uh 94b because it um can be quite
confusing uh between the types of
charter schools and how they're
authorized and so forth um so there is
that attempt uh to go on um and just
just know that they you have to read
194b carefully if you're looking to do
any um uh research there or uh drafting
of new legislation
yes so very quickly
18966 which is the data inventory uh and
policies you're going to find that on
page 522
home education which I know is the
discussed on Monday is chapter
193a and you're going to find that on
page 564
and very very briefly I'll just draw
your attention on page
565 to RSA 193 A3 which is that rulle
making
provision here it's set out in its own
subheading its own
law the State Board of Education shall
adopt rules pursuant to again those are
that those magic words those legislative
magic words that give the the state
board and the Department rule making
Authority and tells the department what
the rule making should should
cover it's interesting that in this
particular chapter the rule making is
its own statute there's so many
different ways to do it you can include
it in a provision you can make it its
own provision but these are just some
examples as you begin your process of
legislating and policymaking of how to
structure sh so I just highlight these
for
you RSA
194d is open enrollment
schools and you're going to find that on
page 663
and RSA 195 are cooperatives
one I I only chuckle because
representative cordelli is grinning at
me as we talk about RSA 195 Cooperative
school districts there's a an enormous
amount of history as we look at
cooperatives there have been study
committees created legislatively that
have looked at this issue uh typically
when 195 D is or I'm sorry 195
Cooperative schools are brought up it's
really important to recognize the
history of them it's worth bringing in
the school boards Association or another
attorney who really has worked very
closely with cooperatives there's been a
lot of frustration as to how the law is
written and how schools can successfully
withdraw from cooperatives but when we
look at cooperatives there are times
where just understanding kind of the how
did we get here is pretty critical and I
think this is one of those areas
representative cordellia I hope I didn't
speak out of turn um but it is just a
really complex area I know historically
one of the conversations has been about
what role the State Board of Education
plays with cooperatives when a
Cooperative is formed and when they are
dissolved it goes before the state board
but I know from my my work at the
department the question has always
been and then what what does the State
Board do what role does the State Board
Play and so these are some policy
considerations to think about when you
look at 190 uh chapter 195 and I would
be so bold as to say it is worth getting
the history
lesson on cooperatives certainly can't
come from me but there are other
attorneys who um who have come before
this board and would be willing to do so
again who would explain that and it's
it's worth taking the time to really
understand the nature of
cooperatives two other areas that they
won't necessarily come before this
committee but it's worth being aware of
rsa1
91a is New Hampshire's right to no law
right we're familiar with Foya which is
the federal version in New Hampshire
it's 91a you will find 91a in this book
there have been times
where I was just laughing at myself
because I was flipping the pages as I
said you'll find 901a in this book and I
wasn't finding 91a in this book I was
like I hope you find 91a in this book
and you do luckily uh you find it near
the beginning of the book and I'll get
you the page number we all seem to like
that
but right to know is its own
chapter and it
begins on page 20 oh page 16 um it's its
own chapter and I bring it to your
attention one because we often reference
right to know it's worth looking at that
chapter and what it covers
and be mindful that there have been um
policy debates as to whether or not this
should be applicable of right to know
91a it has its own chapter so just be
mindful of that cross reference it
always makes me nervous when the right
to no law is it referenced somewhere
else it does have its own
chapter so just be mindful of that it
would might already be exempt under the
committee but restraint and seclusion
obviously affects Public Schools I think
it's worth knowing the chapter 126
U that is also an area that will often
get amended and I want to highlight
something for your attention on 126
U 126 U is found on page 88 that's the
beginning of the chapter
but when we look on page
89 there are two definitions that I want
to bring to your attention I want to
bring it to your attention for a couple
of reasons I understand as a policy
matter this subject is dealt is handled
by a different committee but this topic
affects education and schools it's worth
noting and I also want to identify for
you
that when we look at the definition of
the term restraint and you'll find that
on page 89 in that left hand column down
near the
bottom the definition goes
on quite a
bit and it's broken into these subp
parts but what I find fascinating about
the restraint and seclusion
law is it's the only area that I've
identified that the definition also
talks about what is not
restraint that's an interesting way to
create a
definition so you have a definition of
what that term means but when you look
at the top of the column on the right
hand side in subsection e it says
restraint shall not include
the
following they do the same thing for the
term
seclusion and as I work in Restraint and
seclusion I've never seen a def a
definition written that way I just found
it fascinating again another reason
nobody hangs out with me I get it but I
found that fascinating so as you do your
work as policy makers think about how
you can craft these
definitions there might be times where
you need to talk about what is not
covered by the term the only area I
found it is here in 126 U restraint and
seclusion defining what it is and what
it
isn't and I think it's a really
interesting way to approach a very
complicated topic but it gives a lot
of a lot of direction to the field so
again I highlight it not that you're
going to work on 126 U but given the
work that you do in education it's
certainly worth knowing that restraint
and seclusion is housed in 126
you representative cordelli with your
permission if we could take a five
minute break are you okay with that
that's that's great yes good
idea I'll come back at quarter
after
e
e e
if uh everyone could take their seats I
think we're about ready to uh reconvene
I fell for
it all right well then I set the bar
really low because I forgot to turn on
my microphone so now when everyone else
does it you can just blame it on
me so um all right I'll draw your
attention back I appreciate your
patience um as we go through this
so you each have a booklet of the code
of
conduct I want to highlight it for your
attention because it probably will be
something that you're discussing or at
least referencing as you go through your
policymaking
role if you look at 12 page 12 of your
statute
book H those of you who closed your
books no
no you you you failed the test we got to
always have the books
open if it makes you feel better I
actually drive around with a copy of the
books in my car which again is why why
nobody in Amherst or Milford hangs out
with me right there you go um so I have
a copy on desk and a copy in my car at
all times good times huh but that's how
important they are and this is really
the key to your policymaking success so
if you look at page
12 on the right hand
column there was a bill passed back in
2019 and it provided
for and you're going to see it in
subsection double C1 The
Establishment and enforcement of a code
of ethics and code of conduct for
licensed certified educational
personnel and then it sets forth these
these four
principles that is the code of conduct
that is the establishment legislatively
of the code of conduct it was a
directive to the Department of Education
you are to write the code of conduct I
highlight the code of conduct because I
think it's a great example of the
legislature setting out the groundwork
here's what we want it to cover we want
it to have these four
principles and and the department and
the State Board is going to enter into
rul making to flush out what those
principles look like I go back to my
example of the framework of the house
and then the wallpaper and the paint and
the
appliances this is a really great
example of it this is the law this was a
bill that was brought forward to this
committee and debated and
passed and then this was created these
are the rules this is the code of
conduct it's not often that the
department takes its rules and puts it
into a little book like this the rules
can be found on our website we'll look
at that in a minute but because this
governs an Educator's credential or
their license um this is why the
department created this
booklet it was passed in 2019 it has not
been amended since that time so I know
it looks old but it's still valid um
because it hasn't been amended so when
you look at this the first
section is the code of
ethics the code of ethics is is not
enforcable it is inspiration AAL
aspirational um it provides guidance to
Educators but
it's it's not enforceable but on page
eight it shifts to the code of
conduct and there's a definition
section and then if you look at page 11
it goes into the various principles and
those
principles were not created by the state
board and they weren't created by the
Department of
Education they are based on the law as
written so you look at page 12
responsibility to the education
profession and educational professionals
and it's mirrored right
here but what the rules do is flush out
what that
means so I think it's just such a great
example that the legislature gave a
directive here's what we want it to
cover and the rulle making then really
gets into the detail of what that
means so the code of conduct is it's not
an employment issue it is a licensing
issue it is the difference between
employment and
lure and the department has this booklet
and administers uh sanctions on an
Educator's license if appropriate if
there is a found violation of the code
of
conduct and there are times where the
code of conduct is brought up proposed
to be amended added to what have you and
again I reference 21 and9 which sets out
that legislative authority to create a
code of conduct and then the ru making
piece of it so as you do your policym
think about if it's an amendment to the
code of conduct in terms of adding
another uh responsibility or another
principle or if it's a rule
piece that wants to be amended any
questions on that because the difference
between employment and licensure can be
sometimes
complicated a few other things to be
mindful of as you look through this this
law
book and we'll stick with page 12 12
since we're already
there at the bottom of page 12 has a
little highlighted section in bold
amendments that gives you a very brief
history of the legislative changes which
have occurred to this section of the
law there have been times where I have
gone through that and looked at how it's
been changed over the
years it's a helpful quick reference
there are times where the amendments are
so vast where there it's a complete
rework that it's not going to be able to
be caught in in the word of the day
blurb um it's just not going to be
effective and you might have to do some
more legislative history to really find
out what that prior amendment was but
this is a really great starting point
the other area that I will bring your
attention
to is references to case
law you're not going to find references
to case law in every section in the
education book it's very different than
in the criminal code in the criminal
code you will find countless references
to case law not every education statute
is going to be litigated to the point
where it becomes case
law but there are sections where there
will be case law
references um and you can find one on
page 13 where it says notes of
decision and under that very brief
heading it gives you a very quick
summary of what the case is and at the
very end of that it gives you the case
name and the citation so it says 20110
190 NH
727 that's the case
name you can find that case I can help
you find that case we can access that
case again not every chapter or
provision in the education book is going
to
have a case reference but if it does it
might give you some
guidance so it's worth at least looking
to see if it's
there I want to spend a brief bit of
time if you flip to the back of your law
book
it's worth becoming familiar with the
index this is the paper version of
control
F right it's not as much fun I like
contrl f as much as everybody else but
the index can be very
helpful it's
designed I think it's a little
counterintuitive I've struggled with it
from time to time in large part you know
you're going to have it's an
alphabetized index which we're all used
to but a lot of
information is under the generic
heading of School elections School
funds schools and school
districts and you're going to find that
in i44
it starts on the very bottom of i43 but
you're going to see how expansive that
heading in the index is so when you look
for a particular topic and you're not
finding it in the alphabetized version
you're not finding it at as its own
heading look under school and school
districts I'm not sure why it's grouped
that way but there have been many times
where I've been successful in finding it
in that general area so again this is
the paper version of control F it's not
always pretty it's not always fun but
it's a great
resource couple of just other things to
be mindful of and we've talked about a
lot of them as we've gone through
because I've tried to use sections of
the law to really highlight these
Provisions I didn't want to just drag
you through the law book without a
purpose and a
Direction but be mindful of that Ru
making provision I've highlighted a
couple of examples for
you as you as this uh legislative body
goes through its policy
directive be mindful of whether rule
making is necessary and if it's
necessary to use those magic words rules
adopted under RSA
541a and then give the Board of
Education and the department the
directive as to what the rules should
cover and don't be shy about looking at
other areas that we've highlighted and
mimicking how other areas have been
drafted I think CTE is a great example
CTE really told this state board what
the rules should cover code of conduct
set out those four principles and those
four principles were used
verbatim but the department and the
State Board had discretion as to what
those principles then covered so as a
legislative body those are things to be
mindful of and do not be shy of looking
at the areas we've highlighted and
saying hey it was done really well in
this area let's mimic it
here that's why it's all laid out for
you the other area that this legislative
body should be mindful of is it's always
at the very bottom of the proposed bill
I sometimes forget about it as well it's
the effective
date I will tell you anecdotally here is
what happens with effective dates no one
pays attention to them until
May because in May we're starting to
wrap up we're starting the we crossover
has occurred we know what bills are
going to eventually end up on the
governor's desk and that is when as a
department myself included guilty is
charged we start looking at oh when is
this
effective and we need to be mindful of
the task we are are putting on whatever
the school district or the department or
whatever the entity is when that
effective date is is there enough time
is there enough runway for the entity
that is affected to make that change and
be and be successful at it there have
been times in my testimony where I have
requested this legislative body to be
mindful of giving the department enough
time to be successful in
implementation and so this is probably
my own may aopa but I'm here to say uh
together working hand inand we can be
mindful of effective dates because I
have often times forgotten about them
until it's almost too late but it is
something to be to be mindful of whether
it's going to be effective July 1st of
this year January or you know two three
years out we've had one bill that um I
had I think it was um two-year effective
date and so the department wrote a
technical advisory on it and had it
ready to go and then we rolled it out
when it became effective so it's okay to
give uh you know a significant Runway of
a year if it's appropriate
but that's something to to be mindful
of other areas of information um dep
Department website does have an enormous
amount of information it does have
access to the rules and we could go into
the rules in more detail the general
court website also has the laws and it
has the rules there are countless rules
that the department has governing almost
every area of the section whether it's
home education or special education or
CTE all of those are going to have
rules and you can find those on the
general court website you can find them
on the department
website every year the department does a
legislative summary so if you are
curious as to what happened in Prior
years the legislative summaries are on
our website I'm happy to provide those
to you we also have technical advisories
we do not issue technical advisories on
every law that has passed but any law
that we feel the field would benefit
from guidance on or there's might be
some confusion um we will issue a
technical advisory on and you can find
those on our
website so we talked about a couple of
them um restraint and seclusion we
always issue technical advisories
on any changes to 18911 the Civics and
government law we always issue technical
advisor on and if there's an area um
that anyone would like a technical
advisory on we're always open to taking
requests and we'll consider whether
whether we can do that um so it's kind
of an ongoing conversation but the list
of technical advisories goes back years
so my only caveat is to be mindful that
it is still relevant and still
applicable
law I think that's all I have and that
is um a picture of my favorite lawyer uh
on the slide there so I'm happy to take
any questions I'm happy to take a moment
to go into our website if you think that
that would be helpful but I also know
you have an afternoon ahead of you of
hearing some bills and I've never heard
anyone complain of extra time for lunch
so well thank you very much very uh
informative um for all of us um any any
questions
for Miss Venton
um uh but uh we will see her quite often
yes um I have the cheap seats in the
back so right I just wanted to follow up
with a couple of things um one we
talking about the references and
amendments that you'll see in there I
wanted to mention we also have uh Gen 4
is our committee researcher so if the
committee wants research done Jen will
do that for us but we each have individ
ual research is available in legislative
services so you can go to OS research
section and put in a request for
research for them to do and they will do
that for you I had one request I can't
remember what was for but they went back
to
1860 for me looking at for information
about
legislation um so that's a great
resource also and um
uh these books um are extremely valuable
as you have heard um and I I guarantee
right now they still fit in our drawers
in our office um I don't know how many
more years that'll uh before we have to
get new drawers but um you know they
still fit and I will also mention we do
have I I don't it probably won't come to
us but for the second or third time
there is legislation to re Rec codify
the education statutes to revamp them
because um one example that Miss Venton
pointed out was uh the change for the
special education uh ages to 21
inclusive rather than to age 21 and
we've had to go back two or three times
to amend other sections to change it to
21 inclusive
um because they were missed um so
hopefully the problem with
recodification is um who wants to do it
who wants to go through this thing um
any money involved yes
okay not that much um but uh there is
another bill to do that and um the
possibility of some former OS uh people
to to do that work so um we'll see what
happens happens with that
um anything else
um and just very briefly if I may um
when you're looking at a at a
provision it's probably worth looking at
when it was first passed looking at that
Amendment section there are some areas
as we have talked about that are looked
at just about every every legislative
session and then there are other areas
we have a a law currently on the books
that was passed in like
1929 and but we are still held
accountable to that law passed in 1929
and we had a situation recently where um
I think the secretary States I'm trying
to find it here and I'm I'm not
successful in finding it of course uh
which is just the right the way of the
world but there was a law passed in 1929
or 1932 and the secretary of state has
to hand the department written
constitutions and we to provide those we
meet that obligation we had a citizen
call us to say what are you doing to be
in compliance with this law and there
had never been another amendment passed
to it it's just been quietly sitting in
the lawbook and we met Our obligation by
providing that information online I find
it fascinating and again this is why no
one hangs out with me but the law says
lawbooks and now the Technology's
changed so much that we can meet that
obligation by doing it online but that's
just something to keep in mind as we
look at that recodification of just
making sure that the laws are current
and I would be remiss if I did not um
also just highlight for you again we've
talked about asking what is the proposed
Bill trying to do is it creating a new
section is it repealing is it amendment
is it amending look
for forgive me as I get up here look for
the strikeouts and the Bold
italics that lets you know so you can
have a proposed bill that's many pages
in length and each section will be doing
something different so there might be a
section that's repealing something there
might be another section that's amending
and you're going to see it with the Bold
italics so it's very you have to be
really careful to just read what each
section is doing um because I certainly
have fallen into that trap where I
haven't read it carefully um but those
are some of the key things to look for
the strikeouts and the repealing
language and the Bold
italics great thank you thank you very
much we really appreciate your time the
session um before we actually Break um
representative Snodgrass um uh we went
around and introduced ourselves um be
glad to have you introduce yourself
before we break
okay my name is j and con and I retired
um I was previously I was executive
director of a nonprofit educational
Corporation Called second start that
operated in conquer for lots of
populations that that needed additional
assistance adults that hadn't finished
high school um refugees needing English
as a second language um we had an
alternative high school program for kids
that weren't uh making it in the public
schools um we also had drug and alcohol
counselors out in schools and we had a
daycare center so it was a fairly
comprehensive program and I did that for
48 years and decided it was enough so um
I was asked if I would consider um
running for the house and um here I
am is that quick enough
or e
El oh could you hear me sorry right
native
I'm sorry I yeah you really got
to
yeah
e
e e
Well w welcome back committee um I hope
you had a nice extended lunch that'll
probably be the last extended lunch we
have for the year
um uh and um I just wanted to point out
that the um Alliance for Charter Schools
left off some information for each of us
so that should
be on your
desk and um we have our first bill um
and for those who are interested since
we had a session on these books in the
morning the statute in question is on
page 762 in your
book um oh big FX Mr
chair and um we welcome the prime
sponsor representative Al Ander who has
the honor of presenting the first bill
in history to the education policy and
administration committee so so welcome
representative well and thank you Mr
chair and I'm I'm quite honored with
that distinction hopefully the first
bill of the committee will pass out of
this committee as well um that's the
plan anyways so for the record my name
is representative Joe Alexander um this
is my fourth term I serve the town of
gtown um I filed this bill on behalf of
my SAU which is SAU 19 they represent go
toown in New Boston um I I'd like to
introduce this it's basically enabling
legislation that follows What towns can
already do um which gives school
districts the same opportunity to have
voters in their Community decide to
appoint a school district Treasurer
instead of electing one um I sponsored
it on their behalf and it's my
understanding I have my business
administrator here to answer technical
questions but this is really enabling
legislation voters can choose to put it
on the ballot um and then that process
can be changed if it passes on town
warrant on town meeting day so with that
that's it happy to answer
questions representative Cornell so the
treasurer is just a treasurer for the
school district because I know in
Manchester we have a Treasurer but it's
for every city department so it's
different so this is just for the
schools yeah that's a great question
currently there's a a school and a town
Treasurer so this would just bring towns
in line where they can both have the
same opportunity to appoint a Treasurer
relative instead of electing one um so
for instance some towns may choose to do
one or the other but goof toown for
instance has two we have a town in
school thank you welcome representative
selling thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question just to clarify um
because I got a little confused in there
so this would bring the issue before the
voters of a town so that they would vote
on having their treasur be appointed
supposed as opposed to yes voting on the
treasure yes so this could be submitted
by either petition warrant article or
the school board may choose to put this
on as a as a procedural change and then
the voters will at on town meeting day
um put an up or down vote on
that yes represent LEL thank you and
thank you for taking my question can you
I just want you to help me understand if
you could I thought right now as it
stands you can have someone on the
ballot and then if someone doesn't run
for the position or if they resign then
they can be appointed is that
correct yes okay thank
you any further questions from the
committee uh seen none um You probably
be one of the shortest testimonies of
the year as well you know and short and
sweet and to the point right thank you
very
much and we have Mr gross from go down
the um
superintendent business administrator I
appreciate the promotion but
um thank you Mr chairman and and thank
uh you folks on the committee um I did
uh ask or we did ask at sau9 uh
representative Alexander to sponsor this
leg this enabling
legislation and um I first want to say
that I I hope that this is perceived as
a bipartisan Common Sense enabling
legislation uh first and foremost I want
to thank representative Alexander for
sponsoring this bill and for being here
today you know why is this legislation
important um simply put and it was
clarified I I Believe by representative
Cornell that in uh cities you you might
have one person but in many communities
you have a school and a town Treasurer
the legislation uh was was aorded couple
of decades ago which would allow towns
the ability to vote on having an
appointed Treasurer so in gtown there is
an appointed Treasurer from the town
side but there is no ability to do that
on the school side and arguably the
school's budget the numbers of
transactions are probably double that of
the town but yet we are um challenged
sometimes uh with respect to that
because there are times when you have to
release payments that are out of
sequence and you have to get a hold of a
Treasurer the treasurer might be on
vacation uh Etc and it becomes a
challenge uh in that respect so um I
wanted to just also share with you um as
I see that you have um the books of all
of the rsas the treasurer duties is uh
for schools is 197 col
23-a treasurers duties and they are
voluminous um and many of these
functions are done by the business
office and the business operations and
they're kind of reviewed by the
treasurer um but the duties of a
treasurer for a town in this case a
school are massive um they are largely
done by business offices or Finance
offices across New Hampshire and the
requirements and the um accounting Savvy
the finance Savvy that is needed um I
think it suits it uh suits us a little
better for communities to have the
ability to a point um not to say that
they will but at least give them the
opportunity give School school districts
the opportunity to have their voters
decide whether they wish to have their
Treasurer appointed so I think that's
the nice thing about enabling
legislation it does give that choice to
uh to those
communities um and you know again I just
want to reemphasize that um timel I also
want to stress that we have two very
good treasurers right now um they do a f
a really really good job I will also
state that both of them have Finance
backgrounds and accounting backgrounds
friends um that has not always been the
case in my uh job okay so I'm really
blessed but part of anything is planning
for the future and planning for the
future I think these jobs require people
to have these set skill sets we're
blessed to have two people that do but
that might not be the case in one year
or 10 years from now so that was
it thank you very much uh yes
representative Terry thanks uh I'm I'm
not seeing a lot of of a other people
here to testify today I'm not seeing any
uh Pink cards so I'm just interested to
know from you whether you have spoken
with colleagues and other communities
throughout the state and whether you
have some sense from them as to whether
they would be favorably disposed or
really would like something like this in
addition to you in your school district
sure um I belong to an association as
called the New Hampshire uh administ
business administrators Association
essentially and um they they don't Lobby
they don't take official votes on
legislation I can tell you anecdotally
in conversations that I have had with my
peers that um this type of legislation
would be very helpful to them and it
gives them the opportunity to have their
Community make a decision to go that
route and I think that's all that this
legislation does it provides an
opportunity for a community to
collectively decide whether they'd like
to have an appointed Treasurer thank you
yes representative
Bon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I'm just curious
about uh the impetus for for this uh
Bill normally uh your school district uh
Treasurer is elected by the body is your
concern that the uh uh the folks coming
forward to be elected as treasure aren't
necessarily qualified to do the
job um I believe that if you look at the
qualifications and the duties that are
required under RSA
19723 a are voluminous and they require
individuals with a background in finance
Andor accounting uh to perform the
duties as been statutorily written um
right now I think if you ask business
administrators or town finance officials
they will tell you um that largely this
is done by staff of a school school
district and signed off on by a
Treasurer um but they're largely done
when you're talking about massive Bank
reconciliations um I can tell you that
our
treasurers um are sometimes three four
months behind and it we we do them
obviously you know one month back they
could be three four five months back um
if you're looking about who
collateralized funds Etc the business
office sets those not the treasurer so
when you look at all the duties and I
would encourage you to just take a look
at 197 colon 23A and you'll see that
more and more
requirements dictate somebody with that
with that skill set and um it also gives
you the opportunity to if you did
appoint um you would be able to
determine does that person possess those
skills I can tell you from gtown we have
an appointed treasur that appointed
Treasurer also happens to be an employee
of the town in the in their finance
office and that person is very
well-versed in all of the requirements
so it it's quite helpful to to know that
and have that trust if we're truly
looking at making sure that there is
accountability of school finances and
town finances this gives communities the
opportunity to ensure
that yes U just a followup to that um I
think you kind of answered it already so
so it sounds like what you're looking at
is your example being that you have a
person in the town office that has those
um abilities that now has been given
those extra responsibilities typical the
treasure in our school district is uh um
reive some sort of stien so you're
envisioning perhaps somebody within the
school district just assuming those
responsibilities with a statement um
that is not always the case in terms of
um if it is an employee of a finance
office it could just be part of their
duties there would not be any additional
compensation so right now in the
communities of Goffstown and New Boston
the treasurers receive modest stipend to
perform those duties um in Goffstown as
I can't speak for any other municipality
in the state the person who performs the
duties of Treasurer on on behalf of the
town of gtown is part of their job
duties it is they are not receiving any
extra compensation you could make a very
stretch argument that it would save
school districts or towns money because
they would not have to provide that
modest
typend thank you
okay yes representative litfield thank
you thank you for taking my question
could you give me a little bit of back
or us a little bit of background on the
history of why this was an elected
position to begin with I I almost feel
as though we're giving up a type of
check in Balance here so I just want to
understand what the history is behind
this actually being elected
unfortunately representative litfield I
am not going to be I do not have that
knowledge I I I did review the statute
and it was first created in in the year
1887 um and presumably at that time
there were Ledger books and uh having
seen The Archives of gtown and their
Ledger books uh it was not a ton of work
to do um the amount of financial
transactions nowadays would would
warrant it um I do believe that there
regardless of whether or not a Treasurer
is appointed by a community or uh the
community allows for an appointment or
whether it's an elected position the
same duties and
responsibilities um are enumerated in
the statute and the checks and balances
are numerous um uh School districts are
required to have a financial audit every
year um they have to provide uh finance
and data reporting to the State
Department of Education and there are
numerous um things that communities do
in terms of publishing data providing
records so I believe just me personally
that there would be sufficient checks
and balances to ensure that there is
transparency and accountability for an
appointed Treasurer just like there
would be for an elected
one any further questions oh yes repres
Freeman thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
gross for coming in front of us um in
the event that this goes on the ballot
and the voters have decided they'd
rather have this as an appointed
position as opposed to an elected
position would there be any um would
there be any lack of constituent
services and what I'm trying to ask you
is right now as an elected treasurer do
they provide any constituent services
and would they lose any being
appointed in my opinion this is my
seventh year uh working for a school
district I worked in the private sector
for the 29 years prior to that um this
the treasurer Pro and the two treasurers
that I have worked with um have not had
any reason to provide constituent type
Services um in terms of there were if
there were any any right to no requests
or if there was any you know federal
information requests that all comes to a
business office or a finance office so I
don't recall uh treasurers ever holding
office hours or anything else like that
so I don't think there would be any loss
representative
Freeman uh any further questions from
the committee seeing none thank you very
much for being here today thank you
everyone for your
time uh is there anyone else who wishes
to
testify seeing none and seeing no um
further pink cards uh we'll close this
he hearing and we have a few minutes
until our next hearing at
2:15 so you guys are uh getting a easy
day today to start off
with
e
e e
going by the uh clock on either clock on
the wall I think it's uh about time for
our next um hearing um which is on uh HB
1116 um relative to reporting
requirements for
publicy and um we welcome the prime
sponsor representative
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair I'm
representative Jess Edwards representing
Rockingham District 31 uh consisting of
Auburn Chester uh Candia and Deerfield
um I'm here today um providing
constituent Service uh a few months
before our our bills were due um I went
to visit the Auburn Village School while
they were in a meeting and I asked if
there was anything I could do for them
in this coming session and uh in that
public hearing uh it was requested that
I propose this bill which is now HB
hp16 basically at its core if you if you
look at the text it just jumps out at
you on uh on the page where all the bold
letters say uh public Academy and uh to
put that into
context you already are aware I'm sure
um that we
have um RSA 198 colon 4-D Delta uh
reports required in that all of our
governing uh School boards are required
to provide provide some financial
reporting and
disclosure um because uh Pinkerton
Academy is U uh quasi public mostly
private uh institution they were not
covered by this RSA so what this RSA uh
uh proposes is that we ask Pinkerton to
uh complete the same sort of um
Financial disclosure and and financial
transparency reports as public schools
so that that was that was the initial
Direction and concept in the last uh few
days um I'm I'm aware that um the Auburn
Village School school president Alan
villino who is here today to testify as
well as um um Tim Powers is here uh from
Pinkerton to testify and they've had I
think a productive conversation about
what the information needs of uh ABS and
the other schools that serve that
Pinkerton serves um so that the school
board can access the information that
they think they need in order to be able
to negotiate properly um and um Mr
Powers uh has thinks that all the
information that's in this standard
report is already available um but it's
in a different sequence and format and
maybe spread over one or two documents
more than than what the the schools are
are U expecting so um I think uh they've
had a very productive conversation
you're going to hear from them directly
because they're here to testify and um
my my position on this is that uh if if
if they can work it out to where the
information exchange is done and that we
maintain trans transparency
appropriately I I I'm happy with that
I'm not really uh pushing to expand our
statutes um or to extend our legal
obligations to the private acmis but I
do think that um Mr Powers is wanting to
make sure that the data necessary is in
fact available it's just a diff
difference of opinion I think on format
but but I don't want to go too much
anticipated their testimony because
that's why they're here and they're the
experts and I know nothing so um except
now I've told you everything I know uh
please don't ask me any more questions
but but I will if you want take
questions um would anyone like to uh
take him up uh on uh and embarrass him
publicly
[Laughter]
represent thank you for taking my
question can you define what
distinguishes an academy from a what
makes a school an institution an academy
so that is a great question and
fortunately we have Mr Powers here to
explain it I I do Health Care finance
and it I have no clue about this
education stuff this is this is the
Smart committee here okay thank you
yeah Corell thank you for taking my
question I I'm confused about what you
said did you say that if they could work
it out themselves you don't care if this
gets passed I I think uh at this moment
it's it's your bill it's in my opinion
no longer matters I I'm just trying to
give you the context um and I I happen
to be a believer that uh better
government relies on fewer laws and and
that we have more voluntary compliance
and people just get along and they seem
to be on the cusp of maybe being able to
get along uh that's that's that's my
observation they're going to come up
here and maybe get into a fist fight I
don't
know repr s thank you I promise my
question is easy I'm just curious how
many um publicy we have in New Hampshire
I believe the answer is three but there
are probably 12 people here who can
correct
me three just
two I I I don't know I thought it was
three I know Pinkerton is one of them
and they're kind of in my my district
F the questions for representative
Edwards uh seeing none no one watch The
Challenge you any further so thank you
very much uh for being here all right uh
thank you Mr chair thank you to the
committee uh Allan villain wave
is that on or off
sorry good afternoon everyone thank you
for uh uh hosting a wonderful event here
today um I I do want to say my name is
Alan Lov I'm been the uh on the Auburn
school board for 18 years uh sort of a
brief period of time depending on how
old you are uh I I'm a little bit taken
aback by some of uh uh Jess's comments
uh
uh Dr poers and I did have a
conversation yesterday morning but uh I
never had a conversation with Jess and
and my conversations with Tim did not
end in a amicable solution to this uh
this is a is a big problem for for our
community and and you'll hear from
someone else that uh we're seeking to to
a a clear playing field for everyone
right so there's two semi-public uh high
schools right semi-private but they're
that means they're semi-public um that
do not report where the tax dollars go
to anyone so we have stuff in our
contracts each town has almost the exact
same contract with Pinkerton when we
first went to Pinkerton we we were
desperate for a change we our school was
attending Manchester schools in the
early 2000s after being uh kicked out of
Pinkerton we had to go to Manchester
we Auburn's had students going to
Pinkerton since 18 18 I believe is the
earliest date so there's always been a
relationship but through growth factors
and whatnot pron asked us to not come
back so we end up in a contract with
Manchester for several years Manchester
schools are sometimes difficult they
were always suffering from budget issues
without control by essentially the
school board you you're you're all
probably well aware of that so we were
able to uh look for a new high school we
tried to build one do other things but
in the end result we we went to pin and
they agreed to take us back and uh we
signed our first contract with them but
the contract that we signed was we were
hand given a contract that every other
sending town has and it was essentially
take it or leave
it well we took it within our contract
is a a phase that every five years you
can negotiate uh with each other to to
change the contract um we happen to
actually negotiate this past year um we
offered perhaps 10 items um uh and we
were told no to every single item
including minor word changes so that
that brings us to this um despite the
thought that they're going to provide us
certain information that they do not
they they provide it their way not the
same way that every other high school in
the state of New Hampshire provides and
coincidentally every Charter School
don't forget you you could you should
lump Pinkerton in as a charter school
because they are you know charter
schools are private Pinkerton is private
so it's much easier have the analogy
that they're up Charter School in terms
of how the documents for the state would
work i' I've talked to the people at the
Department of Education and and that's
how they would use that information is
they would more closely align them to a
charter school because they don't uh
they don't go back it's the form that
we're looking for is about taxes and
obviously uh that doesn't apply in the
same manner there
so we I also happen to sit on a budget
committee that's always always a great
time too uh when the budget committee
asks what are what's going on I can't
answer them we can't tell them where our
money goes at Pinkerton Academy it's not
you know it's not available to us to be
shared sometimes I believe uh Dr power
shared a document with our
superintendent this past January but
it's very general in terms and it
doesn't explain where all of our tax
dollars so we're talking local tax
dollars state tax dollars and federal
tax dollars
it doesn't explain where they go what
portion they go where and what happens
we're not interested in pinker's
finances in terms of how much money they
have or all the other things many
charter schools have separate
foundations that hold all of their
finances but they still report they
still file this report one of the things
that's very uh interesting in that on
the end of this form I think it's an
ms27 maybe at 25 I apologize for not
having that right in front of me but
that document at the end actually
calculates how much it costs per pupil
to be educated it's an incredibly
valuable tool across the entire Spectrum
right
so I think it's it's time for pink to be
brought forward to do the same things
that everyone else does it it's it's
just that simple it's not a giant thing
that they have to you know they'd have
to they certainly work in setting up the
forms or the format of how the
information is presented but they have
all the information it's I'm sure they I
know let me rephrase I know they have
smart people that work there all right
they have very a lot of good people with
within that staff to pull this off so
that's my my beginning
no um in the state law and I was trying
to find it I and I'm not a whiz at it
but in section 198 it talks about this
reporting structure the next section
after that that calls out the remedies
if you don't do it actually has publicy
listed already so I don't know when I
don't know how but sometime it must have
been pulled out but the the remedy
section of the law already has publicy
listed so that's why you know we we
looked at some things and and this
seemed like an easy place to make an
accommodation was to just put this back
in all right um I talked about Charter
Schools this is about fairness equity
and accountability I I'm as an education
committee you guys are gonna have your
hands full all year I'm sure this is a
there's a lot of things happening out
there in the education field um and for
us this is about again just we spend one
almost one fifth of our budget is just
out the door we don't have any say on
what's going on with that money so we
have a $16 million budget or so $4
million um I'm sorry we have $18 million
budget and almost $4 million goes
straight to Pinkerton with no
accountability for what it is and um I
don't think that that's fair to any of
the Auburn taxpayers certainly I don't
think it's fair to the people around
there I I don't think it's actually fair
to Pinker and that they could be looking
really good by the same paper by saying
hey it only cost 13 Grand to educate
your child here versus 18,000 at these
other places right but how they come up
with their calcul
isn't the same as what every other
institution except Co Brown does in the
state of New Hampshire so I uh again I I
I didn't have a conversation with Jess
about my conversation with Tim um so I
I'm we are by no means
satisfied that yeah we'll we'll provide
it to you I I don't want to get into the
issues that are not part of this bill
but I promise you I have zero belief
that the town of Auburn is going to be
satisfied by them promising to do
something we need to change in this law
so that we can just see where our money
goes and how they're accountable to us
as the people who are employing their
institution
so I would I really do seek your your
help and approval for this so if you
have any questions I'm happy to try and
tell you what just didn't tell
you thank you questions represent
selling thank you so much and thank
thank you for taking my question behind
the microphone or behind the speaker um
I just wanted to clarify um are you
speaking on behalf of your school board
or speaking on behalf of yourself uh
just as I make my notes sure this is on
behalf of the Auburn school board thank
you we're all in agreement about
this how many students do you
have uh roughly speaking we have 300
students it
varies uh as you all know special ed is
a a uh um an enjoyable part of this
endeavor provides interesting things all
the
time um any further
questions um yes representative
hul question I'll ask the question again
I think you might have answered it it an
academy what makes a school in Academy
that they're semi-private and
semi-public what makes a school in
Academy it's how they were created long
ago before the rules even came in Pinker
Academy has been around since the early
1800s before there was such a thing as
high school um so there are two Co Brown
and Pinkerton are are in order I believe
you're legislator so you might know
better than I do but they have to be
semiu in order to receive State dollars
because you don't I doubt we fund
anybody no private schools here right
except through another Avenue that I
won't say um so they they in order to do
that and in fact so pingon does a really
good job of a lot of things I'm not
trying to rail against their teachers
anything about that but our I'll say our
contract isn't good we can't do anything
about it it's a 20-year contract
renewable every five years I'm sure
you're aware that it's difficult to
solve a high school problem in in wide
ranging communities there's
uh I I don't want to make this a
contract thing because it's not it's
it's really about reporting and the
fairness of tax dollars that are not
being able to be reported to budget
committees and other people and and
local towns people who were paying the
bill so thank you all right sorry I
might ramble a
bit represent Terry yes thank so if I
recall you say you've been on the school
board for 18 years 18 years okay this
contract is for 20 years yeah it's a yes
the contract were you a member of the
board at the time that the contract was
negotiated and and would I surmise then
you didn't really know at the time what
was going to happen because you're not
happy it so when you when you receive
this contract we were very happy in the
in the first year we received this and
this about contract now right so it's a
little bit different than the bill but
I'm happy to share we signed we we
needed to a place to go they were going
to take us they were going to give us a
20-year contract that's not what
Manchester was doing for us so as a
community we need to solve a problem and
pinkan helped us solve a problem
when it when we were negotiating the
contract essentially they gave us the
contract that they gave to Derry to
Chester to at the time uh Windom perhaps
I can't remember Windom Hamstead so that
was the contract the basic contract that
we had to sign up for it's a take it or
leave it
scenario within that contract it says we
can negotiate every five years
renegotiate terms well we've tried to do
that um there's no again we're in the
contract there's no remedy in the
contract for
anything if they're in breach there's no
there's no answer to it the contract is
is not a well done document but it's not
something that we can ask the state to
do all we can ask is for uh we we signed
it uh and had expectations and those
expectations I guess you would say are
not being
fulfilled follow when did you sign the
contract so I can know how long probably
201 12 so you're 12 years into this with
eight more years to go oh no no no every
year it's a 20-year contract renewable
every five years automatically yes
automatically unless we we have to give
notice we have to give at least a
15-year notice to get out okay so it's
uh okay 15 years is a good long time
right um maybe you could build another
High School in 15 years however it's not
realistic thank you
thanks any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank you all
happy
day um Mr Powers from
Pinkerton thank you for being here
thank you good afternoon thank you for
allowing the time to share uh the
information that we do share with our
sending towns and I have a copy I can
leave it with I apologize only brought
one copy but I can certainly email the
committee after an electronic version of
of this information as well um just to
before getting into a couple of
specifics just to clarify a couple of
things that were just brought up um with
regard to state tax dollars the
education um Aid that is uh per pupil
that is given we do not receive re that
the the local Education Agency which is
the each individual School District
receives that Aid we don't get the state
tax dollars uh we don't get federal tax
dollars either um the federal tax
dollars that we do get go through a
Consortium um through our our CTE
portion like that but the the State
education the individual um per pupil
money goes to the school districts not
to us um and then with the the contract
U piece there we do um it is a rolling
um contract every every 5 years they
have the ability to and the last time
with auburn there were some changes that
we did agree to and and shared back with
them but uh they did not uh respond or
agree to those changes but what I'm here
for is is really about what it is that
we provide um we are ping Academy is an
independent school um we were founded in
1814 uh we have six towns currently that
we educate uh students that reside in
those towns um because we have contracts
with those school boards to provide the
high school services for students that
reside in the community um what makes us
an AC a public Academy um in this sense
is we are an independent school um so we
are a private organization we're
nonprofit organization but with those
contracts to the school boards any
families that have children that are
high school age that reside in there can
come attend and we provide those High
School um Educational Services for them
so we provide reg regular Education
Services we provide special education
services so we have students that come
and they'll they'll be with us until
they're they turn age 22 um so we'll
provide those special education the
Transitional services for them and then
we have the reg regular Education
Services that for the majority and
historically students are in high school
for four years they graduate um and then
they move on to careers the workforce
military uh colleges or universities um
whatever the next step is after that so
those those are what we provide for our
for our communities that we have
agreements with um and by the contract
we have we have certain Financial
requirements that we have to provide to
the to these sending towns
um by September 30th of each year
there's a financial report um that we
sent to them that's based on our audited
financials that happen over the
summertime and in it it includes our
tuition rate the number the average
number of students that we had for the
prior years uh expenses and then the
differences between the actual tuition
and what was built um and for the past
several years at least that I've been in
in this role and I apologize I didn't
name is Tim Powers I'm the head of
school of Pinkerton Academy
um for the past several years we've
issued a credit to them so we we have
come in under budget and we've returned
money to our sending towns um which we
we us as a credit so in the First
Billing of the upcoming year we credit
them that amount um it also includes an
appendix a u which is directly in all of
our contracts and in that is an itemized
accounting um from from Pinkerton by
program so we have a regular red and
then we also break it down by our
special education programs we have a
resource program um n act uh passes
program and an NAC program which are
specialized special education programs
based on the various needs that the
students have
um along with that we also um when we go
through our budget cycle um our Board of
my Board of Trustees uh approves the
budget in November and once that's
approved um I meet with the sending Town
superintendent I give them a budget memo
that outlines the budget for the next
fiscal year so uh this past December is
when I met with them and had a budget
memo that high highlighted what the what
the tuition rate was going to be for the
upcoming year what were the drivers um
if we had an increase um uh many times
you the world we live in right now with
the with inflation and things like that
prices have gone up so we've had
increases we have had some decreases in
some of the tuition rates on our program
um based on uh the number of students
that are in the program what it cost to
operate each of the programs uh but in
that memo it it highlights what are
those drivers what are what are the
things that are causing our tuition to
to increase decrease um and such there
we really work to try and communicate
with our sending towns about our tuition
leading up to it so by contract we have
three meetings per year with our sending
Town School boards uh that meet with the
Board of Trustees where we have
information that we share with them
they're able to ask questions and go
through it and generally in October we
give them a a ballpark of where we're at
and what we're looking at for tuition
the next uh upcoming year and what we've
done the past couple of years is in the
weeks leading after that um I've
communicated to the superintendent Where
We Are as we continue to refine our
budget and get to that budget number so
uh for this past year each week I would
just share what the what the percent
increase on regular education because
that's the biggest chunk of of all of
all their budgets where it stands and
how it's been uh fine-tuned each week as
we go through the budget process until
we get to that final number when the
board approves the budget in November um
that that night that very next day I
share with the sing towns this is what
the tuition rates are um and then
explain when we have the meeting I'll go
through all that information information
with them um we also do a couple of
other pieces of things uh to share with
our communities um we produce an annual
report that kind of gives a a high level
overview of things that occurred last
year so there's a financial aspect of it
where we touch on our our budget what it
was what it provided but then we also
highlight uh different accomplishments
of students um this past year we've been
in a building project so we share
information about where that was um uh
new programming that we may have or
changes in programming things like that
and we produce a copy that we share at
the October meeting with all of our
sending towns and we also have a version
online um we also produce a uh two other
two narratives that speak specifically
about our budget one's a look ahead at
what's coming and one's a look back the
budget narrative is a look ahead um what
the next budget is what drives the cost
um our process and budget information um
this we share I share in a a letter to
our community that it's there it's on
our website um share it with our our
sending town uh superintend so that they
have that information that they can
share with their school boards uh so the
information is out there we're not
trying to hide anything um we we put all
that information out there so that they
can see these are the drivers um and
they have the information when if they
get asked about the cost of Pinker in or
or what what uh what's going into that
upcoming year the other piece we have is
the treasures narrative which is a look
back at the prior year um so at the
after the year's done our financial
audits are done we take a look back at
what uh the previous fiscal year was
what it held what was our actual
expenses expenses um if we were able to
if come in under budget if we were over
budget in any any case um you know we we
try to be as fiscally responsible as
possible and we've been coming in under
budget as close to the budget because we
don't want to have a a big budget and
then just come in under we want to make
sure that we're being very accurate with
it um so we also include the September
30th financials in that narrative that
we share with the towns there so when we
post those documents on our website so
they're there for the public to see um
it's shared out electronically um for
our communities but then also um shared
there and it's in um the past I believe
three years are still posted on our
website so people could go back and look
at it over time um as a nonprofit We
also have IRS requirements we have to
fill out we um we fill out the IRS form
990 um which is is a publicly available
document as well that if you go on to
the IRS website you can search for that
and um and find that information as well
um so in looking at this bill and what
it's proposing
um looked at the the requirements of it
and the information and from what what I
can see and look at the request of the
bill is information that we we are
already currently providing to our
sending towns um so we just look at it
as from the standpoint of it's it's not
necessary in the sense from information
that is being asked for um I think Mr
vill spoke to spoke about a couple
things and we had a we had a long
conversation yesterday and um may agree
to disagree on certain things and I
think this uh a place that we can move
forward and to continue with with
conversations because at the end of the
day um we're very proud of the education
that we provide uh for our for our
students for our communities for our
families and um at the at the low cost
per pupil that we're able to do it um
and we try to make sure that we're very
efficient with everything and and share
and answer um questions that our um
communities have uh for us as they're
going through the
processes thank you very much for your
testing
yes representative M thank you Mr
chairman thank you all for being here um
you did mention that there are six town
service by Pinkerton Academy does that
include towns that may send their
students there just for the CTE program
no so we
have uh so we have we're a regional CT
Center so we have contracts with six um
what we're adding a seventh town
fremonts in 2026 so anyone that lives
there can attend for the high school
purposes but uh we are one of two CTE
regions in region 17 us and Salem are
the two so any high school student in
that region which would be uh Windham
pelum uh timberlan can also access the
CTE centers um so the region is divided
between the two centers so um primarily
students from timberlan uh will come to
us we have some pelum students and some
wiam students based on the programs that
we offer uh but those are students that
will then come to us um for those
specific classes okay thank you you're
welome yes representative
Morris hi thanks for taking my question
um I just had one question on cost per
pupil like what the average is uh this
year our our regular education rate is
uh $1
16,38 thank you you're
welcome representative Hall thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question could you identify at least one
or more things that they information
that they want
that you're not giving them I mean it
sounds like we heard this stuff that
you're not giving them but your
presentation just acted like you gave
them everything yeah where's the
disconnect um I I think part of what
they and at least my understanding and I
can certainly be corrected if I'm wrong
with this is when we look at the tuition
for the upcoming year or changes is like
what is constituting the change so like
what what are some of the drivers to uh
the increase in tuition um our increase
in budget we have you know having those
conversations like when um yesterday Mr
Villanova and I had a conversation asked
about like flat budget and they said the
current year we're in we're we're pretty
much in a flat budget our operating
budget for regular education from last
year to this year went up by
0.14% um all of our budgets all of our
special education budgets and regular
education budgets combined went up by
0.45% um and that was totality for all
of it for all that we that we do um so I
shared that information with them you
share we share um you know the big what
some of the bigger drivers are and for
for I think for all of us for all our
districts human capital um salaries and
benefits is the biggest driver and uh
We've looked to maintain competitiveness
with our sending towns and what they're
paying their Educators and their support
staff and the others around us so that
we can make sure that we're um
attracting top top talent top Educators
and U maintaining them uh with us uh
looking at our utilities and and other
expenses like that um capital projects
that we have um maintaining our our
facilities and our campus sharing th
those information that pieces with
him representative Woodcock thank you
chair good afternoon thank you for being
here um the follow two questions will
follow I me on representative Hall's
question my first one is there an out in
the contract so that students from
Auburn or any of the ass signing towns
do not have to go to pick iton so the in
the agreement that I have to look at
Auburn specifically I believe it's 90%
okay is would would attend so there is
the ability for 10% to and that would
just be to attend a public or it could
be 90 each contract is slightly
different so it could be 90 or 95% the
other percentage could attend any other
public high school if a student uh or
family chooses to send their school to a
to a trinity or to Philips xer that
doesn't come into play at all with those
percentages thank you Mr chairman follow
thank you just a follow to represent
Paul's question
so if I understand that that understand
non public private I got all that and I
understand that in your in your mind
you're providing all the things Arin is
asking for in their mind they're not is
there something is there
some specific reason why pinkton would
not accommodate uh using the format that
all the rest of the schools and state
use part our contract is very specific
with the form that's in there um and we
look to uh tweak the the form the that
we provide to share information um and
our districts asked us not to one of our
districts said no we need it in the
exact form that's within that contract
um so we we provide it in that in that
format um appendix a is what it is um
referred to as as part of the contract
um so we go through that and do it um
looking at doing it a different form so
we it would just be a duplicate
duplication of work um so initially like
the first part of looking at it is we're
already providing it if we're going to
have to provide it in another format in
another manner another way um then it's
just it's a amount of resources that
we're then putting into uh to produce
that document when we're already
providing it and it in a specific manner
thank you thank you chair uh represent
Terry yes thank you uh did I hear that
you have uh contracts with six
communities uh and if so or whatever the
number is if you would tell me sure so I
don't have to ask for a followup uh
would you indicate to the committee how
many of the other uh towns or
communities that send you students uh
have contracts that are I'm hearing
boilerplate uh thrown around here as far
as contract format so any of the other
communities have you heard any
expressions of
dissatisfaction or um a desire to have
there be compliance with um what is
being proposed here or is this do you're
not specific to this particular
Community Auburn sure so we have
contracts with six towns as seven town
is being so we have a contract with
Fremont that starts in 2026 so we have
six current towns that uh that attend
the seventh is coming on there um as far
as concerns are uh are um raising
questions about it I I think every town
asks different types of questions and
different information and that's part of
why we've added in um producing budget
narratives and treasure narratives to
explain and to add um add color to the
numbers so it's not just a num on a
spreadsheet that there's there are the
words that explain U those as well uh to
say that all of them are asking for this
no I mean this is the this is the first
time that one of them is um directly
asked uh for that specific document um
that I'm aware of um you know so I think
the others you know if they have
questions they they ask and um I work
closely with their set their
superintendent of schools and when they
have questions about certain things that
they ask me we have we have good
relationships and and share the
information that they're asking for uh
in a timely manner with
that U I was just wondering if you have
an idea on
enrollment um total enrollment and uh
how many um of those students uh come
from the six sending towns sure uh right
now our total enrollment as of our last
report
was
2,980
students of
which it looks like
2,923 would be from our sending towns um
the other students would be um private
pay students that we accept um followup
if I might um the uh um which we heard
about um Regular Ed versus special ed do
you have separate rates in your contract
for students who um qualify as special
needs yes yeah so our special education
so we in know a simple way to and it's
it's way over simplification of it is it
an alart piece so if a student is a is a
specialed student and they um their the
IEP calls for and their specialed team
decides that that's the proper placement
for them there is a there is a different
rate that uh that goes for them whether
it's the the resource um or passes which
could be addition to the regular Ed
tuition or if it's act or NECC which
would be just the Standalone rate that
is charged to specifically for for those
programs thank you you're
welcome uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um to follow
up on chairman cordell's question you
mentioned you have different rates I
know that there's also a different range
of disabilities um do you kind of
compound question do you take all uh
students with all disabilities and if so
are there different rates according to
the disabilities correct yes
so the the quick answer would be would
be yes but there there are some um some
disabilities that are are are we're not
able to to provide um which other public
schools are not able to provide um other
school districts and they they have them
for out of District placements um there
are different rates um but we do work
closely with our with our sending towns
we had the NECC program was one that we
added uh about seven years ago and that
was in response to one of our
communities that said that they had this
population of students coming and they
asked if we could take a look at it and
if it would be a program that we could
offer to keep those students in District
to keep them uh to send them to us as
opposed to sending them to an outo
District placement um so depending upon
the program and the intensity of the
program and what the needs are um there
are different rates um because the the
NECC program is with us year round
except for like two weeks in August the
ACT program is with us for um 11 months
they're not with us for the basically
most of them not all of the month of
August um so the different rates are
there and then based on the other two
programs based on what the needs are and
um in order to meet those needs there
are different rates for the other two
programs as
well rep
Murray thank you Mr chair um with regard
to your rate setting and and special
education rates how are you
differentiating the rates specifically
with regard to parity in in the Learners
based on the specific needs that they
might have so there it it depend on so
there's four main programs which is re
we call it our resource program um which
is the most common that's the biggest
program of all um we have uh roughly 00
students that are within that program um
and that would be like the if we're
thinking of special ed that would be the
the lowest tier meaning the the they
would need the least amount of
interventions um for special education
uh they have a a specific uh resource
room where they go where they get extra
supports whether it is about um on
Executive functioning or if their
disability is math related or or reading
related where they get extra Services
there um within that program the program
is designed to meet those various needs
in this in that capacity in that level
so it's even though there are various
needs within the level um there are
they're relatively the same when you
look at whether it's the math the
executive functioning ADHD whatever
whatever that may be the amount of work
that takes to meet those is relatively
the same so that's why the cost for that
program um you can have a variety of
reasons for the needs there but it's all
the same there when you get into the
other ones that's when the needs become
more intense um or more more is needed
um so whether it's the the emotional
support that's needed um or if it's uh
different physical or um mental uh
handicaps that are that are needed to um
have Services provided um that go into
th those specific programs and there's
more time and more um work needed
whether it's through speech OT uh PT um
even within the classroom U the
different life skills and the courses
that those students could
take you're welcome
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so I I have my public
school hat on right now and I know you
mentioned independent so I'm hoping that
you can just help walk me through this
when you mentioned that they're giving
the they're given the cost per student
is that just based on expenses or are
revenues being shared with the sending
towns uh so the the revenues are being
shared as well um with the the fact that
what we charged for the tuition was the
amount of money that we brought in um to
offset that and then the expenses or
what what it cost based off of um the
expenses for the year for those specific
programs so may I follow
up so what I'm what I'm trying to
understand I think I hear what you're
saying but what I'm trying to understand
is private schools different they're
going to have these meetings behind
closed doors right Public Schools you
would have these meetings out in the
open I was wondering if number one if
these meetings are public and number two
the forms that go to the doe I can't
remember either if it's Ms 25 2710 I
forget at this point uh but that would
actually disclose the revenues and the
expenses to get to the I feel like I'm
hearing that's what Auburn is looking
for but I maybe
misunderstanding yeah so um yeah I I'll
leave this so that uh everyone will be
able to see um what it is in there here
here but uh on it it it lists the it's
it's on the expense side of it so our
revenue is the cost the tuition that we
charged so when we go and look at it um
we know we had our tuition rate times
the the number of students that was our
revenue and then we have our expenses um
that would go offset off of
that thank you and so I just want to
make sure again I understand so there
are no other Revenue I heard you say the
state goes to the town you're saying
there are no other Revenue sources what
ever other than the sending towns so
that's why it's such a
simplified um calculation any other
revenues we have like we we do uh we
fund raise and we do advancement efforts
there um that the monies that are there
those are not um expenses that are
charged to the town um so that is that
is completely separate so there there
are certain things that we've gone out
and we've fundraised for um we installed
two uh artificial tur Fields um we we
fundraised the money to install those
fields um so that was not part of the
tuition so that was not part of of our
expense and um revenue for that f for
those fiscal years that it
encompassed thank you you're
welcome representative Freeman did you
have a question I did Mr chair okay
thank you thank you for coming in front
of us so I I I also have a question
about how you're reporting out seeing as
you're a a a nonprofit private school
and you're designated as
a as a nonprofit with the federal
government do you have to submit
financials to the State Department of
Education such as a traditional public
school or chatter school um and I I I'm
curious about that the the the reports
that we send to this the to our sending
districts we send those same reports to
the New Hampshire education department
and they and may I have a followup yes
thank you thank you um so they would
they look like the traditional yeah
budgets that are submitted to the to the
state doe are they different because you
are a nonprofit private correct they are
different than because we are a
nonprofit private um so our format is
different than what the traditional
Public School form would be thank you
welcome any further
questions uh yes representative
Lichfield I'm going to preface this with
it it may not be fair to ask you but if
you know are the private school form
forms Financial forms consistent that
the doe requires or are they do they
vary I I don't know I know the what the
form we we submit is the one that is in
the contracts with our towns that's the
one we submit I don't I can't speak for
for any of the other other private
schools so thank you you're
welcome very much being here your
testimony you're welcome thank you is
there the written part here can I leave
um you could leave them with the um the
representative at the end and he'll get
them to the clerk and we'll make a
copies for everybody perfect thank you
thank
you
coms um Mr
Royal bernardson Richard Richardson ah
sorry
good afternoon my name's Richardson
press the button
please like
so good afternoon my name is RO
Richardson I live in Chester New
Hampshire 18 Town Farm Road um I spent
19 years as a member of the Chester
School Board uh retiring from office in
2024 uh most of that time I spent as the
chair of the board so I spent a lot of
time working with Pinkerton on budgeting
and financing I did provide a written uh
testimony for you folks which I sent to
the chairman and the vice chairman and
the clerk yesterday uh so I'll try to
keep my my comments
brief um thank you for allowing me to
testify today one aspect of this bill
that I feel is critical is that it would
require under title 198 section 1984 co-
D that a financial report for each
public Academy shall be filed showing
the summary of receipts expenditures
according to uniform classifications
during the proceeding fiscal year and a
balance sheet showing assets and
liabilities at the close of each year
each statistical report submitted under
this section shall include
certifications signed by the chairperson
of the appropriate governing body the
Board of Trustees of approved public
academies under the pains and penalties
of perjury that all the information
contained in this document is true
accurate and complete that's the same
requirement that every School board
chairman has to meet each year this
would bring the financial reporting of
publicy such as Pinkerton Academy and
dairy in alignment with the financial
reporting obligations of local school
districts in New Hampshire as I
mentioned I spent 19 years as a member
of the and frequent chair of the Chester
School Board the Chester school district
is one of the sending school districts
that has a tuition agreement to send our
grade 9 through 12 students to Pinkerton
Academy for their high school
education uh similar to Auburn actually
longer than auburn I guess this is a
long-standing agreement that's stating
back decades originally signed in the
1960s
to be clear I fully believe that sending
Chester students to Pinkerton Academy is
the best option for our community and in
fact I was responsible for negotiating a
a rewrite and a renewal of the current
governing tuition agreement on several
occasions as an elected member of the
Chester School Board my charge was to
represent our community's taxpayers and
to do due diligence when authorizing the
expenditures of any taxpayer funds the
Chester School District typically spends
SE several million dollars each year in
tuition payments at to Pinker Academy it
represents approximately 25 to 30% of
the district's annual budget each year
to support approximately onethird of our
total student body uh approximately 250
students at pinkton about 500 students
at 10K through 8 at Chester Academy the
lack of transparency when dealing with
pinkerton's Board of Trustees on
financial matters was a consistent
source of frustration over my term on
the Chester School Board while a bottom
line figure for the annual Pinkerton
Academy operating budget was furnished
each year in order to justify the annual
T tuition rate calculation the details
were usually tightly held by the
trustees it was only through persistent
questioning and negotiating that
specific details of the expenditures
might be provided but the seldom
provided the level of transparency that
is required of a public school district
given that the tuition charge by the
academy is funded by taxpayer dollars it
is an ongoing frustration for Local
School District board members that they
are not able to easily account for how
these taxpayer dollars paid to the
academy are actually being spent and for
what purpose the proposed change under
consideration today would simply hold
the Publicis to the same reporting
standards as local school districts
regarding the expenditure funds received
as Revenue in the form of tuition
payments which are provided by local
taxpayers I do not see this reporting
requirement as burdensome but simply an
extension of good accounting practices
transparency and a true partnership with
the representatives of the local school
districts to be clear the intent of this
change is not intended to restrict or
change the Board of Trustees existing
prioritization or decision-making
process regarding expenditures
associated with their operating budget
however it is about transparency
regarding the use of taxpayer dollars
supporting that budget for this reason I
urge the members of this house education
policy and administration committee and
your colleagues in the legislature to
support this bill brought to you today
by Representatives Edmunds and Moffett
Edwards and Moffett excuse me I would
also like to commend my former colleague
Au School Board chair Alan Viller for
taking on this issue and initiating
these discussions with representative
Edwards the adoption of the language and
House Bill 116 as presented would
clearly correct a serious shortcoming
that has existed for many years thank
you for your time and service and
support of the education in New
Hampshire if you have any questions
please let me
know thank you for much for being here
and you said you submitted your uh
written testimony via email yes I did
yesterday we'll we'll look for
that um questions representative
litfield thank you and thank you I I'm
trying to understand here I I I can see
where you're coming from but my question
is we're talking about they owe
accountability to the taxpayers but
you've entered into a private contract
with them haven't you it's your account
ability is to the taxpayers or the six
sending towns and right now am I
understanding correctly that I believe
the average cost per student is 19,000
in the state of New Hampshire 19,000
plus 20,000 actually 20,000 okay and
Pinkerton is educating at
16,38 per student Ju Just to be clear
that's their calculation not one created
by the State Department of Education I'm
just wondering if this is outside figure
you're using is calculated by the state
of New Hampshire calculated by Pinkerton
right okay thank
you and actually the the cost of
education for student in Chester I think
it was last year $1
17,36 uh further questions from Mr
Richardson uh representative Woodcock Mr
chairman thank you the question actually
is for you yes or um not the speaker um
would this impact Cole Brown as well if
this bill passed in your that's my
understanding okay thank
you any further questions I seeing none
thank you very much for being here Mr
Richardson you're welcome thank you
that's all the cards we having
right
e
e e
I'm going to turn the gavl over to Vice
chair
Noble since I'm going to have to do this
sometimes I figure I better rip the
Band-Aid off
today um so um House Bill 184
establishing a committee to study
changing school start times and I
welcome the prime sponsor representative
wheeler thank you very much Vice
chairman Noble chairman cordelli and
members of the House Education policy
and administration committee uh I
congratulate you all on your appointment
to this new committee and look forward
to seeing the work that you guys do HB
1884 was brought forward because of a
group of parents that came to me in my
district and told me about how they were
concerned about how early their students
their children were waking up and uh I
know that because I remember having to
get up at 6:00 in the morning to if not
earlier to make the bus at 6:30 uh and
going to class at the 7:30 hour during
the first period uh and I remember how
that affected the day when you're a
student in school and how that makes it
significantly more difficult to go about
the day when you have your first period
as I said in my written testimony
whether it's algebra or photo and video
those classes are significantly harder
when you're starting so early in the day
uh so what I decided after researching
this issue over the course course of the
last year was that a stick was not the
right approach to this legislation the
issue is significantly complex and there
are as I'm don't need to tell this
committee a number of complexities
around the start of school whether that
be the student schedules the teacher
schedules the busing companies servicing
multiple districts throughout the state
that start at different times and the
buses using those different school
districts start times to
pick up people at a certain time uh so
this is a very complex issue and moving
forward with a stick by saying here's a
mandate from the state you will all
start at X time would not be the way to
do it so I proposed a legislative study
committee made up of members of the
house and the Senate to look at this
issue which people across the state are
concerned over you'll have in your email
a
correspondents from members of school
boards from nsha and conal and a few
others who I've spoken to about this
issue there will be Educators that reach
out to you and students and parents and
I have a few parents and students here
today that uh took the time to come out
and speak to you about why they'd like
to find a way to make their school start
a little later people have gone to their
school boards across the state and have
been told by their school
boards their school board members that
this is such a complex issue that it's
one the state should study and look at
before we can move forward on so I'm
here today uh to move that forward so
that those parents that are across the
state trying to make sure that their
kids are healthy and public schools are
heard and I thank you all very much for
the time that you have given me and
happy to take any questions
thank you representative Willer
representative cig thank you and thank
you for taking my question it's nice to
see a hello Committee Member from a
previous Committee in this room um so
I'm curious about your comment that
people have got a school boards and had
difficulty with this I um my children
attend the oyer River School District um
I think it was I don't know 15 years ago
a group of parents went before our
school board and said we have a problem
with school start times we' like to
create a study committee the school
board approved it approved a local study
committee they came back with their
report and there was a meeting of the
town where there were I think three
public hearings and as a result we
changed our school start times um which
we were able to do because we have our
own internal bus system that manages our
students although it was still
incredibly complicated to do and very
specific to managing our four schools
buses and then coordinating with the CTE
that had different start times for the
high school students to navigate all of
that but I'm curious why you think that
school boards wouldn't allow parents to
create a committee within their own town
to study this and and make sure that
it's truly local control around what's
best for that individual town or school
district and we're part of a Cooperative
District to be clear well thank you for
that question I have in my notes here
that Oyster River is a district that
moved forward on this and Kenai has had
conversations conille has had
conversations and
uh I believe I'm missing one but but
that's okay there are there are
districts that are talking about this
and it's not to say that every District
in the state wouldn't move forward on
that it's that uh people have been met
with this is such a complex issue that
we would hope the state studies it and
and that's why I'm here
um I'm sure there are districts
throughout the state that would move
forward on this issue but given the
conversations that I've had over the
last year people were excited by the
prospect of a state committee that could
look at this issue uh and study it from
a state perspective sort of Bird's
bird's eye looking
down representative
McDonald thank you representative and
thank you for bringing this forward I
have a bit of a similar question as the
last one that was posed um I know in
Salem particularly our scoreboard has
looked at doing this actually as a
result of a student petition to look
into it and ultimately ran into an issue
with busing especially since we do have
a CTE Center would make it difficult so
when I look at lines 10 and 11 of this
bill where it says legislation that
would most effectively allow for changes
to school start time I read that as if
the goal of the committee would be to
change school start times or encourage
school districts to do that so is that
your intention and what would you say to
a district like Salem School District
that already tried and wasn't able to do
that well I would say local control and
I would say what that line says the
committee shall study what types of
legislation would most effectively allow
for changes to school start times I
think that's just the charge of the
committee and it would allow for a
broader spectrum of let's see what Salem
has done what Oyster River has done what
keenh high is doing from the broader
Statewide perspective that we have here
in the Legislative Office Building to
look at and come up with a potential
solution this is a study committee so
we'll even if there was a solution that
came of the study committee it would
still have to come back to the
legislature for approval um so this is
just to give their an official committee
that can look at this from a bird's eye
view and take the information learned
from what Salem has gone through what
Oyster River has gone through and the
other school districts to see if there
is some kind of through line that can be
found through what the different school
districts throughout the state have done
and if I may have a followup um you
mentioned that it might take into
consideration what happened in Salem OR
in Durham it sounds like would there be
an um initiative to invite perhaps a
member of the Salem school board or
someone else throughout the state to
come and speak to the committee every
study committee that I've been on and
I've been
on two or three maybe four have been
very productive and those committees
without having to be commissions that
say within the legislation these are the
members outlined one member from each
School District throughout the state
have been able to bring people from each
district all the uh example of the
parole study committee that I was on two
years ago uh and I guess was approved
again we'll see what that looks like in
this next legislative session but we
were able to despite being a legislative
study committee comprised of members of
the house and the Senate bring in people
and people were excited to come in and
tell us about uh what was going on in
the parole system and I'm people on that
committee had very different ideas as to
what the solution that we would come out
of that committee was with um but it was
just an opportunity for people to say
there's this study committee here we can
go to the L and and share our story and
um I would imagine that this would be
the fourth or fifth committee that I'd
get to serve on which would be as
productive uh and would bring people
from all 89 school districts together
all uh people from the School Board
Association uh and others to discuss
this issue moving forward okay thank you
thank you
representative wuk thank you madam Ain
share appreciate it I want to follow up
on R McDonald and down here as well the
same the same essence of the question
but is it your thinking then that the
commission be able to provide a a uh at
the end a summary of data and data
points for these schools to take or is
it your opinion that you think the next
step is that the state is going to say
we've seen these data points okay and
we're going to tell you to do this
I don't think that's for me to say I
think it would be for the appointed
chair of the study committee to study
this issue and come up with a report at
the end as study legislative study
committees are commissioned to do uh
what the content of that report would be
would be up to the chair my idea would
be to as a said to representative
McDonald come up with a comprehensive
approach to look at what school
districts across the state have done to
come up with a potential through line to
make sure that our students can wake up
uh healthier and happier and learn in
the public schools thank you thank you
madam chair thank
you representative
Terry um I I have read rather um
extensively if not intensively on this
particular
issue um but and so I and I'm aware that
other states have actually initiated
study commissions with respect to the
issues involved
relative to uh what what is what's the
best time for a school to start for uh
children of particular ages as I read
the the line 10 three duties um it
appears to me is that the charge to the
committee is to
just study what types of legislation
would most effectively allow for changes
to school start
times and and it presupposes their for
that there should be changes or are are
are are you looking for any kind of
study here would it be done by the state
or by a special study committee or are
you seeking to empower local communities
and school boards to undertake these
studies prior to however they would
choose to do so if they choose to do so
I I'm I'm just I'm a little foggy on
this well representative Terry I was
afraid you were going to ask a question
because I haven't read profiles en
courage yet but soon enough soon enough
I will read the book that you were so
generous to give to me last year and I'm
looking forward to it but to answer your
question this would be a study committee
around the issue and I would hope that
at the end of it as somebody who
believes in moving forward with starting
school later that it would help in
compiling data to potentially come up
with a solution in a separate bium that
could be worked on from this committee
and from the legislature that would
address the issue but the matter at hand
with the study committee itself is just
to compile that data and to look at what
the potential is here for a through line
in starting school later in the state of
New Hampshire and maybe uh if I could
just maybe the solution that the study
committee finds is that there isn't one
and that local control is the only way
to move forward but as as you said there
were other states that started with a
study committee and were able to despite
the complexities find Solutions so I
think this is to me just a step forward
to see what other potentials are
there so would you be open to uh
language that would be would give
greater specif specificity to the the
target to actually uh study the issue
itself rather than just The Changing
Times which would be the outcome
potential outcome of recommendations of
such a study would you be open to
language that would effectively broaden
this and
clarify or do you think it's not
necessary it's not my bill anymore it's
yours so I would be open to whatever
change the house education policy and
administration to achieve your objective
to achieve the objective of uh organized
coherent study and approach to looking
at where that through line could be
found to start school later thank you
thank
you any other
questions oh representative
moris hi um thank you Vice chair Madam
chair thank I'm still learning all the
terminology it's my first term here so
um it is my understanding that by the
potential later star times would also
equate to a later end time in schools
which could possibly save parents money
in After School Care thank you that is
correct representative Morris there are
some benefits despite the complex
negatives that are here when it comes to
busing Etc there are some absolute
positives to this um not just the health
of the students but yeah we could reduce
child care costs if school started later
um and I would have to say you know even
with the busing situation I mean the
busing company shouldn't determine what
the schedule of our students in the
public schools are so whatever is best
for the busing company might not be best
for the student and and so I would hope
we could look at that issue with the
busing companies coming here the school
boards coming here and and and all the
uh people who are involved coming here
and talking about just those issues
sounds like you want to be on the
committee thank you and maybe I don't
know any other
questions seeing none thank you
representative wheeler thank you very
much Madam
chair it's all time in this place
um representative
Penza thank you madam chair that's cool
to say um my name is representative
Kelly Penza I represent straford
District 19 uh in Rochester um now I'm
totally going to date myself um my
previous life I worked in for a higher
educ
uh marketing organization before that I
worked for Babson College and then um I
was there uh for about 10 years in the
space um I also did educational
Consulting for a long time I have
studied this issue extensively so this
um subject really came hard-hitting in
the 90s um I graduated from high school
in
1991 uh representative Noble knows that
as well
um so um
it's been Crystal Clear unfortunately
it's taken a very long time for all of
these studies to come forward so this is
a fantastic study um I would love to be
part of this I just don't know if I have
enough time um but I would you know be
very happy to provide all of the
research that's been done for decades on
this um you know adolescence alone this
is um they need between the ages of 13
18 they should be sleeping between 8 to
10 hours per day um that's according to
every single study from American Academy
of sleep medicine to Pediatrics to
Psychiatry all all the gamut and um all
the outcomes show so there like more
than 500 different school districts
right now in the country um that have
done the later start times um and I love
how the representative wheeler ended
with about we shouldn't be having an
outside busing company driving the
health and well-being and the academic
Integrity of our students um I also at
the same time that I studied this
subject I also studied trimesters I am
all for it um the the learning Gap in
the summer um is is huge uh I wanted to
I actually uh applied to work for a
college that was doing it it trimesters
so it gave breaks all throughout so you
don't have huge learning loss where
you're spending the first you know um
month or two of the school year having
to have relearned everything that you
forgot about over three months of a
summer so it was at the same time that
these things happened um and it's an
easy thing really that can happen um so
you know the studies it's an easy thing
that that can happen like through
legislation of course um to to fix
something that could help um overall all
of the uh students in our state so
during puberty I wrote this down
um youth have this undergo in their like
their internal clocks so it actually
makes them harder for them to fall
asleep at night and all these things
will be um discussed and then um they
could also stay awake longer um before
experiencing an increase in the pressure
to sleep so there's all of these things
that are just happening because their
bodies are changing um and all of that
so I remember when my girls were um in
fifth and sixth grade um and that bus
Ian they had to be out there um one of
them had to be out there because it was
two different buses 6:20 in the morning
and I just couldn't stand that so of
course you know I brought them to school
just because of that and I wanted them
to sleep in later but I I think
everything there's so many benefits even
with child care and all those types of
things so I highly encourage you guys
and I think it's a great point that you
made representative Terry it's your bill
now I think you can expand that line 10
to be more inclusive so it's just just
not focused on the legislation but uh
you know if I have the time of
Representative wheeler I'll I'll I'll
join this or provide as much information
as I can this was my wheelhouse so in
the back in the
day any
questions seeing none thank
you El
Zimmer can the come up together sure
is it okay if I go first because we kind
of sure thank
you um hi
I'm shorter than everybody
else hi I'm Kiara and I'm a sixth grader
um why we shouldn't have to wake up
early to go to school I woke up at 6:00
in the morning last year some of my
friends had to wake up at 4:00 because
of the buzz schedule wake up that early
is not healthy for developing kids we're
supposed to get 8 to 10 hours of sleep
and I know that most of my friends are
getting a lot less than that since
school starts early and kids do not
usually wake up early that means that
kids run late I know from experience
that there is so much happening all at
once and it's really chaotic when
everything is so crazy and you're so
stressed out it's really easy to forget
things like instruments or homework it's
also not safe to go to the bus stop in
the dark one of my peers was walking to
the bus stop in the dark and he saw a
dog like animal he assumed it was one of
his neighbor's dogs as he got closer he
realized it wasn't it was a
coyote uh sorry getting up so early
means getting up so early that it's dark
means that there are wild animals around
waking up
I last year I went to a public school
and this year I I'm going to a private
school um I did that because waking up
so early took a mental toll on me um I
woke up feeling exhausted stressed
irritable and sad it affected my entire
day this year I wake up feeling
refreshed much better and I'm on
time thank
you um hi um I'm L I go to public school
every day and me and others have to wake
up at 6 and earlier every single day to
go to school making them tired and
unfocused some even sick making them
Miss even more school than they do when
they're
late
also the time we go to get to the bus or
walk or drive is so early that it's
still dark outside making it hard to see
creating many problems
such as like cars on like busy
intersections ice and
animals another problem with waking up
early is that it makes people sleep in
and forget stuff they would normally
know like setting alarms making parents
late to jobs because they have to drive
their
kids um let me just get over here
um this also affects the teachers
because they have to um wake up earlier
than the students to go to school to
teach
them um what do you think where's my
spot um yeah that's the
end um
hi
I'm hi I'm Siara and I'm a sixth grader
at sou medal
school kids at my school usually get
about 5 to 6 hours when they should get
8 to 10 and if I don't get enough sleep
I don't feel good and end up missing
more school days it's also harder to
focus without much sleep teachers could
also benefit from getting up later cuz
they have to get up even earlier than
students
teachers don't or kids don't have time
to eat breakfast in the morning if they
get up super early and have to rush the
bus sometimes kids put their heads down
on desks CU they don't have enough sleep
and then they get yelled at by teachers
and sometimes even sent to the
principal's office also cuz it's so dark
most kids have to go to the bus at in
the dark and it's so much colder at
night without the sun in the winter I've
been feeling sick like stomach aches
headaches Js Etc ever since I started
waking up early because school starts so
early thank you very much would you
girls like to take any questions I don't
know if anybody hasn't sure I'm not sure
if we'll be able to answer them but sure
representative Terry yes thank you thank
you for your very uh impressive uh
testimony really appreciate you being
here today and sharing your personal
experiences um I'm a minister and one of
my favorite Bible verses is don't let
the World squeeze you into its mold it
sounds to me like what I'm hearing from
you is that you guys are being squeezed
into adults mold and it's not working
out very well for you by your opinion
and your experiences if that's the case
what time do you think would be a good
time for school to start so that you
would be better off in the teachers too
do you have opinions
um well my the new school that I'm going
to now which is a private school we have
to to like get there from 8:00 to 9:00
and it really actually starts at 9:00 so
just
yeah and it works a lot
better um you guys have any other I
think that's a pretty good time yeah
yeah about M uh can I just ask what town
you girls are from uh pet pet pet yeah
yeah okay representative Cel thank you
so much so I I want to thank you first
of all for your thoughtful testimony
also for remembering that teachers have
to get up even earlier to be there to
prepare for you as a a former teacher in
a school district that um started at
7:00 a.m. I had to wake up at 5: to be
on time myself so I can relate to that
um my question and it may not be as
relevant because I think you're all in
Middle School still at the stage is
whether or not any of you participate in
after school sports and have the had the
impact of that the time scheduling the
timing around that with your schools at
all she does I do too um yeah um
um I don't really know the
answer representative
hul thank you madam chair and thank you
for coming here today to speak to us
it's been awesome my question is for the
one in the middle you said school starts
at 9:00 a.m. what time does it end
um it like we leave pickup is at 3:30 so
we kind of I get back at four um yeah
okay thank
you any other
questions or of
Litchfield thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question and
thank you so much for getting up here to
speak today you are all phenomenal each
and every one of you so thank you my
question is when we're looking at this
probably we're going to have to share
the school bus grades kindergarten
through 12th grader maybe 10th right I
don't want to exaggerate maybe get your
license when you're 16 you can drive how
do you feel about that do you think it's
okay do are you okay with having the big
kids and the really little kids on the
bus or the crazy middle schoolers what
do you think about that um I think that
if people can be
civilized unlike some people that I know
um I think that it would work out and I
think something that's helpful is having
the younger kids sit in the front which
is like what we did in elementary school
the fourth graders would sit in the back
and I think if the high schoolers were
to sit in the back they would still be
some separation but I think it would be
okay you guys
um uh um personally I think it would be
pretty good because on my bus we have
our grade and like all the middle
schoolers and the high schoolers and
they don't really normally cause any
problems so I would say it's pretty good
like that if there were like clear
separations between like elementary
school and middle school and high school
I think it'd be
fine representative McDonald thank you
madam chair and thank you Kier L and
Sierra that was really good testimony
it's always nice to see you come we
don't often hear the student perspective
but probably in this committee more than
others um my question pertains to your
homework after school if school ends a
little bit later would you still feel
like you have enough time to complete
your homework before going to bed I mean
me and L we don't have like that much
homework so I think we'd be
fine sounds pretty lucky um I I go to a
private school so we have a a lot a lot
a lot a lot of homework and like a lot
like we have to do a journal entry we
have to memorize this thing and say it
in front of the entire school do math we
have like art homework but we I most all
of my classmates get all of it done from
the time that we get home and the time
that we have so and I think that we do
it fine so
yeah thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you girls
very big help thank you thank you thank
you
[Music]
I don't know if I'm reading this
correctly but Naomi
Tucker um I'd like to start with
gratitude that we're not starting at 7
a.m. thank you for
that um so I'm the parent of a sixth
grader Kiara and I'm also a
psychotherapist and a Community member
and in all of these roles is this an
close enough okay in all of these roles
I see the impact of early school start
times um we haven't heard too much about
the research except that it exists but
it is more and better quality sleep B
better mental and physical health
improved academic outcomes reduced risk
of car accidents and injuries improved
athletic performance fewer late arrivals
and
absences so we know that human beings
biological biological clocks naturally
lengthen each day it makes it hard to go
to sleep earlier the average human's
natural day length is 24.2
hours humans volunteered to spend months
in the dark to increase our
understanding of biorhythms and the
outcome was that humans days naturally
got longer and longer if you've ever
traveled East and experience jet leg you
know that that is much harder to shorten
your day and go to bed earlier it's much
easier to travel West and stay up later
the situation is only more extreme for
our youth right when middle schoolers
and high schoolers bodies are changing
due to
hormones their circadian rhythms shift
so that it's even harder for them to go
to sleep earlier so right then we're
suddenly asking them to wake up earlier
go against their biology there's a
reason that sleep deprivation is a
torture tactic it is is
torturous and it impacts everything when
we don't get enough sleep so listen
change can be hard and we humans often
fear it maybe even more than I Fear
public speaking notice my shaking
hands but once we adjust to change it
can really be a relief and I'm talking
about relief for the high schooler
working at CVS who told me that she only
gets four hours of sleep a night by the
time she finishes work and finishes her
homework and is able to wind down and go
to sleep and I'm talking about relief
for the students I know who have trouble
winding down and falling asleep even if
they don't have
jobs and then they fall asleep on the
bus and in class and I'm talking about
relief for a kid who I know who showered
and got dressed at night to be ready for
the early start in the morning already
in their clothes when they wake up but
they go in the morning to get their
socks out accidentally pull out their
underwear don't even realize what's
happening until they look down they put
underwear on over their clothes this is
how tired these kids
are I'm almost
done um I also know really personally
the relief that I'm talking about after
a really rough transition to middle
school with daily bedtime and wakeup
struggles that really impacted the
well-being of my kid we moved to a
school with a later start time and the
decrease in stress and conflict is
unimaginable the improved sleep the
return of curiosity excitement and
enthusiasm hearing my kid singing again
spontaneously this is a game Cher this
lets our kids be kids and I want it for
all of the kids of our state so let's
follow the research to relief I urge you
to approve this bill this study so that
we can prioritize the physical emotional
and mental well-being of the Youth of
our state thank
you thank you very much anybody have any
questions representative
NATO yes thank you for uh coming out
here and testifying uh for the uh the
youth and uh it's all about health and
education education is huge um is is
there any national studies that you have
looked into to uh kind of go by yes
there are there there are so many
studies about it being better for
children and so my understanding is that
this bill is to help figure out what
would be best for the students in this
state and how could we make things
happen here that are effective for
everyone um yeah thank did that answer
your question yes thank okay sorry I'm
very
nervous me too
[Laughter]
any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you representative
n thank you madam chair um my name is
jod n and I represent chesha por and
Kean uh I actually think that most of
what I wanted to say has already been
covered but I will address uh what
aspect that I was going to actually as a
mom because it would answer
representative celik's question um my
oldest he's 17 now um and he uh is a
helper for the unified basketball team
at his school um and also he plays
baseball when it's in season sometimes
he doesn't get back until 9:30 or 10:00
when it's an away game and I can't
imagine him having to get up at 6:00 the
next morning um and go to school
fortunately uh what Keen did was we put
out a survey to all of the parents this
was I think kind of as we were
recovering from Co and uh everybody's
getting back into the swing of things
and they said you know when do you think
uh do you think we should make school
start times later we all voted or I
voted I don't know a majority of us
voted and we all said that yes we would
like for it to be later so we were able
to do that in Keen what I see about this
is the fact that you know in some places
it's it's not possible for one reason or
another there are um potentially
barriers in the way we've talked about
uh busing and things like that and I
think that it deserves a Statewide
conversation so that we can decide um
what we think would be the um the best
guidelines to go by um and figure out
how we can do that how we can come
together possibly to do that and make it
work for our children um in their health
and mental health which has been
addressed so I won't waste your time
that's basically what I wanted to chip
in thank you any
questions representative cel thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
for taking my question I'm I'm curious
where Keen like oyer River has pushed
their start time later whether um you've
not had a discussion in your community
which has proven to be a challenge in
our community where we have parents who
are now struggling for before school
care um with the younger children um
with start times because they need to be
at work before the school buses uh get
to the elementary roots and so whether
um that's been an issue in your District
it's I know there's so many different
nuances which is why I think about this
as a local issue but um I'm just curious
whether that's shown up in Keane as well
yeah absolutely I will say that I have
not heard from anyone um about that and
that's not to say that it isn't a
concern uh but starting at 8:30 with the
you know normal kind of business hours
um it does provide for people to be able
to get to work by nine at least if
they're local um but you know it it
might be U an issue for some but I have
not heard that from anyone
any other
questions seeing none thank
you um Angela and I can't quite read the
last
name
okay did you get
that good
afternoon I'm a parent of three school
age kids one of whom is Sierra and I
have two other kids another middle
schooler and then one in elementary
school and um as you heard the uh middle
school starts at 7:15 a.m. and I um I
wanted to just address a couple of the
points and questions that came up
earlier because I'm one of the parents
who's also active within our local
school district of seeing whether we can
make a change locally um so busing
certainly is a challenge I think both in
local districts and I don't know
Statewide as well there may be policies
around how busing has to happen that
could shift and I think with within our
district we've had we did a whole effort
on potentially consolidating schools and
then our superintendent left and so
we've had a hard time sort of gaining
momentum on this issue even though you
know there are kids like you just saw
these three kids that are it's making
their ability to focus in school to be
successful students worse you know each
day so continuing to kick the hand on
the road is hard um another hat that I
wear is I'm the South Meadow School
track coach
and um so I've seen firsthand that it
can be really challenging when some
schools end at 4: and some end at 25 so
we've had track meets that don't start
till 4:30 and my kids are like sitting
around saying oh when is this track meet
going to start and we're waiting for you
know other schools to get out um I also
know for school districts that end later
there's been cases where the basketball
team leaves at 2 and the kids miss two
periods of school so I don't think it's
great when you have school districts
some do it some don't it creates some
challenges um with that so my
inclination is for us to study it as a
state and potentially provide you know a
Statewide conversation and momentum
toward it just being a cultural shift um
that the day is is shifted for our
students um but a couple pieces that I
had written down that I I wanted to talk
to um one is just the personal
experience you know you heard from
Sierra and some of her friends and as a
parent it's really hard having these
discussions that
6:30 in the morning about is the stomach
ache because you didn't get enough sleep
and what's your first class and do we
let you go in late or do we not and um
because as you know when you don't feel
when you don't sleep enough you may know
as an adult you get a stomach ache you
get a headache it's hard to focus and so
it's hard for parents too trying to
discern with our kids when to push and
and when not um also as we know middle
school high school being a teenager is
not an easy phase of life um there's a
lot of complex social social dynamics
and so if you show up and you're
exhausted it's harder to navigate that
um one of my kids had math as their
first block and was having a much harder
time focusing they were half asleep
during math class and I thought oh my
gosh you got to be learning math this is
really important and so as a parent I
really want my kid when they're at
school to have the ability to really
focus um my other middle schooler is
he's pretty good at powering through
just his personality but he gets pretty
grumpy and often in the morning he's
grumpy and he also gets these extensive
headaches that you know I think that if
he was able to be well rested every day
um that wouldn't be happening for him
and he's really clear he had a
basketball game this afternoon so
couldn't come but he really feels like
for both himself and for his other
classmates they would be in much more in
a position to thrive if they were
showing up well
rested um so I really feel like our
Public Schools will be better and many
students across the state would do back
better academically and socially with
this very simple step of of moving the
start time back and this legislation can
help us find the best ways to do that
second I just very briefly want to talk
about from the athletic perspective as I
said I'm a track coach and then I also
have coached many different rep Sports
in our community and we push kids in
sports we push them to run these hard
repeats we push them to do all the
strength work and complicated jumping
drills and when kids get enough sleep
they can do that much better um there's
a bunch of different studies around
sleep um a 2011 Stanford study found
that college basketball college
basketball players shot more accurately
and ran faster after they got more sleep
professional sports teams often track
athletes sleep and it influences the
scheduling of the um games and meets and
there was a study of 160 student
athletes at a Middle High School in
California and sleep ration was the
biggest cause behind athletic injuries
so students who slept less than 8 hours
on average were 1.7 times more likely to
suffer an injury than those who averaged
eight or more hours and so there's also
um an athletic perspective for um uh
another reason behind um encouraging us
to let kids sleep more so I just feel
like the studies are really clear and um
many students and parents would really
benefit teachers too and I think if we
really want our kids in our state to
thrive um I think it's a really
reasonable step forward that we could be
taking thank
you thank you any
questions no thank you thank you for
taking my question it seems like a a lot
of the input that we're getting is from
Peterboro and I I I wasn't clear on what
you said and has Peter Boro been working
on this issue
or that's a good question yeah and I
think
um some of us parents worked on it
locally and then we knew rep Jonah
wheeler and talked to him and we also um
have started connecting with a national
group called uh I think it's called
starts starts I have to look get back to
the National Group but there's different
entities uh across the country that are
working both locally in school districts
and on Statewide legislation and we had
heard that there's several states that
have passed laws you know some are very
simple saying middle school or high
School can't start before 8:00 or 8:30
and then others are my impression more
sort of carrot type legislation or they
may relate to busing or different
changes that are sort of around the
edges of it um but yes we're we're from
Peterboro and before my kids were really
sort of in the mix with school there was
an effort I think like 2017 2018 or so
that there was a whole effort and then
it was put on um as a ballot initiative
two
families um that was a a busing will you
pay the certain amount for busing but I
don't my understanding is there wasn't
as much work done around really
education and engagement it was just
like do you want to pay a whole bunch of
money yes or no and it ended up failing
and then um myself and several other
parents in the last two years I'd say
sort of rebr the issue up our previous
superintendent um was very open to the
conversations we went to some of the
school board meetings and um our
Administration was very clear that it
was the right thing to do for students
but the conille school district was
looking at uh consolidation and that
really needed to be the focus initially
figuring out if we were going to close
some of our elementary schools and then
our superintendent left and so we just
lost a little bit of steam and my
perspective as a parent is that you know
we'll we'll try on all levels we'll try
with our school district we'll try at
the state um but related to some of my
earlier points about Athletics I think
it's a actually a challenge if you have
some school districts go and other
school districts not go and I also feel
like if it's better for all the students
let's have all the students get the
benefit not just some students get the
benefit but not
others yeah thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much Barrett Christina
Barrett I have one request um just for
the benefit of the new people here you
spend a lot of time with us so could you
give a very brief overview of the New
Hampshire school boards Association yeah
thank you very much um chairwoman Noble
and and chairman cordelli um and members
of the committee thank you my name is
barer Christina I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire school
board Association it's nice to see some
familiar faces again I me to the newly
elected people um congratulations on
being um assigned to the to the
absolutely the best committee um in the
New Hampshire House of Representatives
um there's not a lot of work in this
committee it's calm not a lot of
emotions it's going to be it's going to
be a real Breeze for you um but thank
you for that for allowing me to
introduce myself um representative um
the New Hampshire school boards
Association is a private nonprofit
organization that provides a number of
services to school board
um primarily um we provide training to
school boards uh we do about 20 or 25
webinars each year um in between my
staff attorney and I um we go out on
site to probably anywhere between 50 and
80 School boards uh school board
meetings every year and provide a
variety of trainings on roles and
responsibilities the right to no law
collective bargaining effective meetings
good relations between the
superintendent um and the school board
uh we have a staff attorney as I
mentioned he he spends most of his time
answering uh legal questions from school
board members and superintendents on
anything that can happen in a in a in a
particular School District on any given
day today we had questions on um an
individual was requesting uh that um an
agenda item be an individual from the
public was requesting that an agenda
item be placed on on the agenda for the
next meeting and the next email I got
was a complicated issue relative to
health insurance and um early incentive
retirement buyouts from an employee so
and everything in between um uh so legal
training policy work uh I don't know
those that we know have have a handful
of members that serve time on their
local their local school board the new
individuals if you are on your local
school board I'm not aware but we
certainly appreciate you for your
service if you ever did um School boards
are governed by policies and policy
manuals there are about 70 75 policies
that are required by law the school
boards Association maintains a sample
policy manual probably about four or 500
sample policies um that we keep on file
we categorize them anywhere from
required by law um recommended and
optional many of the optional policies
we just keep on file and it's not we
don't put it we don't distribute it out
per se but rather um we keep it on file
so if a school board asks if we have a
policy on topic X we have one on file
ready to go we also have a director of
governmental relations um Becky Wilson
Becky is the educator on staff she's a
former special education uh director
worked in uh building level
Administration for about 20 years before
she came to nhba about 5 years ago so
Becky um has the um background
experience and and expertise to talk
about sort of operationalizing those
School District policies if you will and
it's really sort of our voice for what
it means to be in the building with
students with parents with staff members
um and and what can happen talking about
start times I'll just say Bell to Bell
if you will um myself um I've been with
the school boards Association for about
20 years I started out as staff attorney
for them in 2005 in 2017 my predecessor
uh retired and I was named executive
director so I spend um I spend my day
mostly doing um what my office manager
tells me I need to do um because she
runs the office to be quite honest with
you um but um at at times I do a little
bit of everything I still do a little
bit of the training I do a little bit of
the legislative advocacy um and I do a
little bit of the legal work I don't do
the policy work anymore cuz I I it was a
lot of lot of tedious work um and I'm
glad to be able to pass that off so I if
you have any questions um I certain
members of the committee know how to get
in touch with me um our website our our
emails um and phone numbers are are on
the website and and as I said um you'll
see me from time to time you'll see
Becky Wilson more often than you'll see
myself um and uh and we we we look
forward we look forward to working with
you if there's ever anything nsba can do
to assist you whether it's relative to
your work in this room or relative to
questions that you may have with your
own local school board or Lo local
superintendent over the years I've heard
from members of the committee that
they're calling me not on a legislative
issue but they're just saying hey this
was going on in our school district what
do you you got a way I can sort of work
this out or how do you handle this so
we're here to be a resource um not just
for our local school boards but for um
this committee and other committees in
the legislature as well too um as you'll
find out for example with House Bill 184
I'm not taking a position on the bill uh
we do that from time to time we don't
take positions on bills but rather we
come here um and for example example if
you have a special education Bill Miss
Wilson from our office former special
education director we may not take a
position on the bill but she can sit
here and talk to you for two or three
hours about special education and just
just use that as as as one example as as
I see some Chuckles around the room so
um thank you for the time uh uh
representative Madam chair to let me
sort of fill in the gaps on that um uh
jumping to to our testimony on House
Bill 185 again the school boards
Association is not taking a position on
this bill I think everything um about
nhs's comments um have have already been
spoken both by representative wheeler um
by some of the other Representatives
that spoke and and some of the other uh
maybe the parents that spoke as well too
and certainly I'd be remiss um without
um without recognizing and thanking the
three young women who who came and and
testified it's always great when we have
students in the in this room is isn't it
um so um there are challenges with
school start times um and the test I
think elicited that what I think is most
important um to take away from though is
that we heard that this was addressed in
the Oyster River School District we
heard it was addressed in the Salem
school district and somebody mentioned I
believe Keen if I'm not mistaken but all
three of those were done locally right
the local communities had that had that
conversation um about what was best for
for their community and their parents
and their students um some of the
challenges um with with sort of so to
the study committee it's self nsba would
have no objection if the if the
legislature wants to create a committee
and bring in school administrators bring
in pediatricians or parents that have
studied this and school board members
and the transportation companies and
hsba is happy to be a part of that
conversation and assist with whatever we
can relative to what may come out of
that committee Our concern was and I
think representative Cher you had
mentioned line 10 the committee shall
study what types of legislation would
most effectively allow changes to school
start time sort of presupposing the
answer if you will um as you've heard me
say you the returning members of the
committee have heard me say from time to
time local challenges tend to have local
Solutions um
nhsb usually advocates for local control
and we would oppose you know any any
recommendation from a committee um that
would you know um recommend sort of a
Statewide start time or Statewide
legislation to address this I know
that's sort of putting the cart before
the horse if you will relative to this
bill that's just looking to to create
the committee um if but you know I think
a lot of the the challenges with with
getting some of these start times
perhaps later so so kids can sleep in a
little bit more have been addressed we
have collective bargaining agreements um
Statewide that that indicates start and
stop times if you will Transportation um
has been has been has been addressed um
the needs of local parents obviously um
staff scheduling intradistrict you have
a lot of teachers who are who are
parents as well too and they may teach
in a different district with where they
live so if they need to be in a building
at 7:30 or quarter of eight you know for
their own for their job how does that
impact their ability to get their child
to school at 8 or 8:30 um if if if the
if the if the towns are on or the school
districts are on different start times
CTE schedules um I believe u somebody
may have mentioned so we know sort of
what the challenges are um if this study
committee can help people bring people
together to identify some solutions to
some of those challenges and hsba is
fully in support of that so again we're
not taking a position um I you know the
PE the speakers before me identified all
the all the issues but um I just wanted
to to address them as well too and again
thank you for the time Madam chair for
for the introduction to the committee
and with that I'm happy to answer any
questions any
questions seeing none thank you Barrett
thank you
I guess that concludes our
hearing and I don't have a g so I use my
fingers thank you very much uh um Miss
vice president my vice chair I guess um
and uh I wanted to thank uh everyone who
came to testify today reps and young
ladies as well certainly the young
ladies um I want to thank the committee
for a very productive day um I think uh
we're off to a good start and um the
schedule is out for next week um as I
said it'll be Wednesday and
Thursday um and um uh you we'll see uh
following weeks we're starting to work
on scheduling for the week after so um
we'll try and get schedules out to
everybody for planning purposes as soon
as possible but um thank you again and
we uh
oh okay yes um do you oh we have some uh
some
bills
great so uh it so it has been a
successful
day um so thank you again to everybody
and
um Karen Davis is also the one that
moved all of our stuff from this um from
the drawers over here to drawers over
there and set everything up so thank you
Karen yes without uh uh committee
Services um we would be uh hard pressed
to get our work done do you
need I I have those yeah